welcome everyone to the final day of the
week on our digital marketing journey by
simply learn on day 5 we looked at the
various digital marketing tools today we
are going to learn about paid marketing
paid marketing is one of the easiest and
quickest ways to help customers discover
your brand and offerings with paid
marketing you can purchase advertising
that allows you to Target an audience
instead of waiting for them to find you
organically paid advertising is
measurable and is easier than SEO in
this video we will learn how someone can
make use of platforms such as Google
Facebook YouTube and Instagram for
advertising and growing their business
so let's begin with understanding how
marketing Works through Google ads
YouTube ads Facebook ads and Instagram
ads when you're setting up your brand
and you need to make sure reaches the
Right audience and provide the best
results there's really only one place to
turn to it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on Google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on Google so thank you for
joining my name is Rob Sanders I'm with
simply learn and we're going to talk
about all things Google when it comes to
advertising so thanks for joining and
let's get right to it and talk about
Google ads and its effect with
advertising so we're going to start out
with what are Google ads well Google ads
used to be called Google AdWords and
it's been around a good while almost 20
years now so really Google has grown at
a really rapid Pace it's become one of
Google's main sources of revenue uh you
could say probably in the 90 percent
tile of its Revenue comes from Google
ads and when we say Google ads we mean
people who pay for advertising on
google.com so Google that's really what
it does is it provides services that
fall under the category of PPC which
stands for pay-per-click UA Also may
hear Google ads or PPC referred to as
cost per click or CPC or sponsored
search really what it comes down to it's
a model so when you advertise on
google.com and somebody clicks on your
ad basically you're paying Google for
the click okay so it's just really a
business model where an Advertiser pays
Google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay Google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
I want to advertise my business I can go
to Google ads and say Google place my ad
on google.com and then if my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as I pay Google a
fee so Google ads is just an online
advertising platform form developed by
Google with which advertisers can pay to
display ads they can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobiles involved so you got
all the necessary devices and platforms
available in Google's ecosystem so for
example if I go to Google Search even if
I type in you know what is Google ads
here I could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what our Google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from YouTube you
got a Knowledge Graph here you got
featured Snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that I typed in what are
Google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now now if
I happen to click on any one of these
two and go to that particular
advertisements website they're going to
pay Google a specific cost per click so
that's how it looks on google.com it
really depends on your query and what
ads show up but the great thing about
you know Google ads is they make it
known for the user who's doing the
search query what the ad is so here I
can easily pick out what's an ad a
sponsored search or pay-per-click ad and
what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an Advertiser
advertising on google.com I'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an Advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
Okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organ search here or even down here
doesn't have a little add box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search hat now why do we want to
advertise on Google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so what I mean by that is you
know search is really a great place to
advertise because you're meeting the
consumer halfway meaning somebody's
typing something in and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so Google ads advertises your
product or service to the relevant
audience to ensure the users perform the
action required of them so it's really a
great way to get quality audience to
your website because if somebody types
in something and you happen to offer
what they're looking for basically your
ads going to show up somebody clicks on
it you pay Google for the click and you
get quality traffic and return so the
other great benefit to being on Google
ads is increases brand aware awareness
so it's a great way to get your product
and brand out there Google has a vast
network
uh also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search Network
itself the search engine itself means of
people use it every day in fact here in
the United States it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the United
States so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
Mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of Mind
awareness another benefit to being on
Google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use Google's Display
Network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they're ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why Google offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on Google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so so we can look at
what device what you know browser Etc so
we can really gain some information
about who's coming to the website we
could certainly measure our performance
so with Google we're paying cost per
click and So based on that model you
know we can certainly measure what
keywords what ads are generating traffic
to the website and how much we're paying
for that okay and if that traffic turns
out to be a lead we can measure that
against that specific keyword or ad or
campaign so we can certainly measure our
performance all the way down the keyword
level and can we can measure up against
how many conversions or what we're
paying for those conversions so Google
ads is a very highly quantitative
approach to advertising because there's
lots of numbers involved and you're
constantly collecting information about
your advertising on google.com and its
Network and another benefit really is
this High flexibility so Google ads has
a number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads Dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
Google ads has very flexible options in
terms of advertising and we're going to
talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what I always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider Google
ads because as we've shown here in our
example if I go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are Google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on Google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you could bid on it
so it definitely is a good option if
you're not ranking for a particular
keyword organically so it serves as
almost an option I always say that you
know search is like a fruit bowl okay
you have apples and oranges in that
fruit bowl well the Orange is organic
search and the apple is paid search
they're different approaches but they
share the same fruit bowl the same real
estate so you can really really help
yourself by using Google ads to
complement what you're doing organically
so if you're not ranked organically for
keyword you can certainly use Google ads
if you are ranked for specific keywords
and it's a highly competitive industry
then you can use Google ads to help you
leverage the amount of clicks you get
from that ad so it's okay to be
organically listed and have a paid
search listing at the same time so if we
go back to our example here we could see
wordstream.com has a paid ad and here we
can see just two spots below organically
they're showing up with an organic
listing so you could certainly be in
both positions to try and maximize your
clicks so it's definitely a good
strategy to run with Google ads on top
of everything we mentioned in terms of
measurement flexibility Google ads does
offer a really good incentive to
advertise and let's not lose focus that
again search is really the only medium
in which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for and
when I say halfway meaning your ad is
going to appear for somebody who's
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor or
directions search is there to serve that
that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
Channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be TV or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps OR also known as organic
search but the great thing is Google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift Focus now and talk about the
various formats in Google ads on Google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on Google Search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so JBL headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines in the Great thing about
Google ads with with this text format is
that you can have up to two descriptions
of 90 characters so the headlines are up
to 30 characters the descriptions are up
to 90 characters and so you can really
write some specific information about
your ad about your product about your
service okay and the ad is also going to
contain what we call AD extensions so
here you can see shop by category in-ear
headphones on-ear headphones those are
all site link extensions meaning they're
going to link to something on your
website and so the purpose of the
extension is to help get the click so
the reason why you're running Google ads
is to get the click you want to generate
the click you want to get that traffic
to your website so by writing three
headlines and writing to description
lines and adding extensions to your ad
all help you get that click yes you're
going to pay Google for the click but
that's the whole purpose is to generate
the click from search because remember
search is there to respond to somebody's
need or query and so if you get the
click on your ad chances are it's going
to be a highly relevant visitor to your
website so Google offers up a lot of
opportunity for you to write a lot of
information in your text ad on Google
for google.com so Google also has other
formats and so they also have responsive
display ads so when we say responsive we
mean Google can serve up a specific
image from your website based on what
somebody's looking for based on the page
that they went to so these ads are all
responsive they adjust their size
appearance and format depending on the
space available so responsive can also
be text text and or image and so the
whole point of response is if you have a
large website let's just say with a lot
of different products and categories
like Amazon well it's hard to write
static ads for thousands of particular
categories and products so why not let
Google do the heavy lifting why not let
Google serve up the images and ads based
on what somebody looked at on your
website and so that's the whole idea
behind responsive ads is it allows
Google to you know show the particular
ad that's most relevant to that user so
it's a really a great option when you're
advertising on Google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to Facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on Facebook first
says Google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on Google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for Uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so Google owns YouTube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on YouTube so they could
be Standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are going
to look at your ad before actually
watching the actual video they went to
YouTube for so you have a lot of
different options with video
advertisements on YouTube so the other
AD format you have on Google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they could
see the brand and so it's an opportunity
for you to really drive high quality
traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if I go to Google Search and I
just type in running shoes so my search
results are are going to list not only
some paid ads but a lot of different
options on shopping ads so here I could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names I could see the
price point if I hover over it I can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews return
policy so if I actually click on this ad
chances are I'm going to buy it
otherwise why would I click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on Google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on Google search by certainly really
giving Google access to your product
inventory connecting in some reviews
connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up Google shopping ads within Google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if I'm on Google search you know I can
go to shopping or I can go to images and
I'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and I will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on Google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with Google
you also have call ADS so when we say
call ADS really call only ads are great
for mobile so when you run
advertisements on Google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and Google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so Google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
Google showing your ads I showed you an
example of Google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
Google search networks so Google search
Network really really allows you to
advertise on Google search so with
Google search if I go back to Google
search and I go to all I typed in
running shoes okay here I can see
shopping ads here I can see a couple of
text ads so you have the opportunity if
you're running only text ads to show up
the top and if you're not at the top
then Google will place you at the bottom
so it really depends on the keyword that
somebody's querying in Google search so
it really depends on how many people are
advertising and so what Google does if I
didn't have any shopping ads here Google
will list a maximum of four text ads at
the top and at the bottom any other ads
that weren't shown at the top will get
placed at the bottom so ideally if
you're running text ads on Google you
want to make sure you're always at the
top and I would say between positions
one and three you always want to make
sure you're at the top okay so you can
certainly certainly measure that
remember Google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on Google with a text
ad you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
Google ads is affiliated with so the
first is Google search Okay so let's
focus on Google Search and so basically
when we say Google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
Google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a Google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query there are
going to see results now depending on
the device Oswald so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
Google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above some featured Snippets and
the organic search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again I've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if I scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
class classes on digital marketing so we
could see simply learn here in the
second position why because again I can
see the logo add here okay so I can see
simply learn using three headlines I can
see simply learn using their two
description lines here and I can see
simply learn using some other extensions
with the ad now all of this is geared
towards getting the click so when you're
on Google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on Google search if you're
on Google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if I change my search query and
typed in coffee in San Francisco go my
search results are going to be
completely different I'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to Google my business not Google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on Google search so Google my business
is tied to local listings or Google Maps
and again with desktop which is what I'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely Google local
listings above organic results okay and
if I go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing I'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to Trump any other type of
result on Google search if you can be in
positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called Google search Partners
so if you set up an account and you you
set up a campaign in Google ads you have
the option to choose Google search as
your network and then as an alternative
or an additional option you can
advertise on Google search partner sites
and so some of their search Partners can
range so basically these are sites that
have partnered up with Google that's
allowing Google to show ads on their
site so the sites can range anywhere
between YouTube to Amazon to New York
Times let's take a look at an example it
could even be another search engine so
if I go to say ask.com and type in
classes on digital marketing it's a
completely different search engine but I
can see the same ad for simply learn so
I can see same I could see a different
headline here actually but I can see the
description and I can see some site link
extensions and so so notice the ad is
still at the top in this case it's in
position one and I can see multiple
companies running advertisements why
because they could see ad next to it and
I could see those over over organic
listings so these are Google search
partner listings so you can opt in to be
on other partner sites that Google or
other sites that Google has partnered up
with so you have options outside of
Google search and that option is Display
Network so Display Network allows you to
advertise elsewhere which is outside of
Google search and if you're going to
advertise on Google's Display Network
you have more ad formats Available to
You including image and including video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the newyorktimes.com or
WebMD or marriott.com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell Google hey okay this is the site I
want to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the Display
Network so if you don't want to
advertise on Google search Okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on Google's
Display Network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity get your product and service
in front of a lot of people because the
way the display network works is it's a
millions of websites who want to have
advertising on their site and so you can
really pick and choose a specific site
where your audience is going to be and
get your ad in front of that audience so
you can really retarget to potential
customers so retargeting as we said
earlier is really reaching out to people
who have already been to your website
and didn't perform a particular function
that you wanted them to perform meaning
somebody came to your website from Paid
search on google.com and they went to
page a and then they left so you really
wanted them to go to page B add a
product to a shopping cart and check out
and purchase that product however if
they didn't do that you could certainly
run ads knowing that they've been to
page a and Page B and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website and so that's what
retargeting really is all about and you
can retarget on Google's Display Network
so remarketing your product to people
who previously visited your your website
or even your app allows you to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of analytics so Google's ads has all the
information you need so let's actually
take a look at some of these options in
Google ads for the Display Network so if
I actually go to Google ads and I
actually go to display campaigns I can
see I have a lot of different options
available to me so if I click on
keywords for example okay I can choose
keywords for my display campaign so what
Google does if you choose keywords
basically what they're doing is they're
going to contextually place your ad
based on the keyword okay so that's an
option for you if you're not sure what
websites to be on with the Display
Network you can certainly just add
keywords and based on those keywords
Google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose the
demographics so on the Display Network
you can say hey Google I only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and So based on that
Google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the Display
Network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so Google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if I just choose a particular ad
group now I have specific topics that I
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics I can get really specific so if I
go under science I could see
subcategories under the topic science I
can see chemistry and physics and
scientific institutions and equipment so
I can really pick and choose specific
topics where I want my ads to be shown
as I mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let Google know okay you can
also advertise on Gmail you can also
advertise on YouTube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the Display Network because when you
tell Google you have a specific audience
you want to Target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
re-target them with an app so the
display campaign is very powerful with
Google because you have all these
different options available to you so
with Google ads you can also determine
how well you're reaching your goals
which web websites you're running your
ads on which ads are bringing in clicks
and which site gives you maximum value
for the minimum cost so you can see all
that in Google ads so when I actually
pick and choose how I want to Target I
can certainly measure that so for
example audiences or or demographics for
example if I go back to demographics I
have all this data that Google's
collected on my advertising so I can see
for example by age range based on my
campaign how many clicks how many
Impressions impressions are how many
times my ads been seen click-through
rate meaning the rate at which people
see my ad and are clicking on my ad how
much I'm paying per click CPC is cost
per click total cost and conversions how
many conversions am I getting so I could
see all this data available to me in
Google ads so it's a very powerful
platform for measuring performance okay
let's talk about how you can create a
Google ad okay so so first thing you
want to do is you want to set up your
campaign and you want to align and goal
with that campaign just like we talked
with bads related to Facebook you always
want to align a goal with your campaign
just like we talked about there we want
to do the same thing here on Google so
we have a number of different options at
our disposal so when you run a campaign
why are you running the campaign so if
you're in just to drive traffic or
you're trying to generate brand
awareness okay great you can still set
up that campaign you're just going to
choose the Display Network okay the
Display Network allows you to get your
ad out there on millions of websites so
that people can actually see what your
brand product or service is all about
now if you're into direct response
meaning you're in it for sales and leads
then you probably want to choose
potentially Google search Partners as a
network okay not display but Google
search and the partner sites okay on
Google search so by choosing Google
search as your network it's direct to
response so somebody's typing in a
keyword query and you're responding so
that's the whole idea behind Google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose Google search Partners okay again
if you're into you know driving brand
awareness our product and brand
consideration then maybe you should
choose the Display Network the bottom
line is you need to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign that's the very
most important very first step and most
important step is to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign and once you've
decided that then it's on to setting up
the campaign and in Google you're always
going to have at least one ad group and
what makes up an ad group keywords and
ads so ideally when you set up a
campaign on Google search Network you're
going to choose keywords and those
keywords should be tightly knitted or
tightly themed or in other words be all
relevant to one another in an ad group
so that's what an ad group is keywords
that are relevant to one another okay in
that ad group you're also going to have
an ad so when you choose your keywords
you're going to write an ad for those
keywords so step three is after you set
the ad group and choose your keywords
you're going to create an ad so let's
take a look at how that looks in Google
ads so if I go to Google ads I can see I
already have an account set up I have a
couple campaigns so let's just say I
have this campaign set up here I'm just
going to call it industrial campaign
okay and if I choose industrial campaign
okay I'm going to then be asked to set
up an ad group now if I set up an ad
group already in that ad group should be
keywords and ads okay so remember when
you set up an ad group you want to
choose your keywords first payment is
keyword should be all related to one
another so for example I could see an ad
group here called fig concentrate well
if I click on this ad group and I look
at the keywords they should all be
related to fake concentrate so here we
go we can see a few keywords in this ad
group in fact I have 10 of them all
related to Fig concentrate so it's very
very important from a quality score
perspective if you remember when we're
talking about quality score quality
score is based on landing page
experience expected click through and
the add relevancy to the keyword so if
you can choose a ad group and have all
your keywords related to one another
like I do here with fig concentrate then
it's easier to write an ad okay so here
I have 10 keywords all related to Fig
concentrate so now if I go to ads and
extensions in the Google ads platform we
can see here I already have a couple of
ads going okay so ideally if I wanted to
I can run more than just two ads as a
best practice as a best practice you
want to have at least two ads why
because these two ads are going to be
served up against each other and ideally
the whole idea of running more than one
ad is what Google can do is start
serving up the ad that is performing
better in terms of clicked array or in
terms of conversions okay so it doesn't
hurt to even add one or two more ads so
here I'm going to go ahead and add one
more ad here okay so if I click on that
plus button I have a bunch of options
here I'm going to go ahead and choose
text ad because I'm running this
campaign on the search Network and my
goal is to get sales not leads sales so
I want sales I want somebody to click on
my ad go to my website and purchase just
some fake concentrate so that's my goal
and so if I'm on the search Network I
can only have text ads so I'm going to
choose text at and once I choose text ad
then I have the option now to go through
and create a new ad okay so what Google
actually does is they populate the ad
from previous ads and so this gives me
an opportunity to tweak one of the ads I
already have in place so here you can
see I have a final URL and that's the
URL that the traffic is going to go to
when they click on your ad okay so
somebody clicks on the ad that's the
page they're going to go to call that
the final URL now I have an option to
create up to three headlines so here I
could see headline one up to 30
characters I have my brand name headline
two I have something related to the
keyword I'm bidding on so what am I
talking about fake concentrate okay
again up to 30 characters now that
includes basis so if you happen to go
over 30 characters your ad is not going
to get approved so here you can see 32
over 30 I'm two characters over if I
just get rid of that the ad is okay so
you got to be careful to stay within the
boundaries of the character limits
including spaces so here I got headline
two is Big concentrate now I'm going to
write headline three this is new so this
is recently implemented by Google and I
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise we want to advertise so that
people can see our ad and click on our
ad that's the whole point isn't it to
get people to click on our ad because
they're looking for something that we're
are offering in this example fit
concentrate so here I have headline
three I'm gonna go ahead and put
something in the headline three maybe a
promotion let's just say I'm offering up
twenty percent so I can say up to 20 off
through April and May now you see I'm
running to the character count so I'm
just gonna go ahead and keep it at April
so up to twenty percent off through
April now I can create another ad and
maybe change the headline to say up to
20 off through May so you want to take
advantage of all three headlines now
notice when I added the headline here I
can see a preview of it on mobile and I
could see a preview of it on desktop now
underneath that I have what they call
the display path so what Google does is
they take your domain in this case
valleyfig.com and you can basically
customize that domain with what they
call a path so you have path One path
two and the whole point of this is for
you to customize it based on the key
words you were bidding on so if I'm
bidding on fake concentrate I'm going to
put fake concentrate in here now
remember when somebody actually clicks
on my ad they're not going to go to
valleyfig.com
concentrate they're going to go to the
URL up here under final URL so you want
to make sure you put a path in there
ideally what I would do is put in
something related to the keyword I'm
bidding on in this case click
concentrate now I have an opportunity to
add a new description a second
description this is new and I have up to
90 characters so I can go ahead and add
some content so remember with
description two I have up to 90
characters so I'm just going to go ahead
and borrow some copy from the website if
I'm not actually sure what to write and
so here you can see thick concentrate is
a natural product containing no
preservatives or additives so that's my
second description so now I can go ahead
and save and create extensions so I'm
just going to go ahead and push the
button save and create extensions and
when I do that I'm going to be prompted
to go ahead and create some ad
extensions and so ad extensions allow me
to add in links site links underneath
the ad just like you see here so when
you've added your site link extensions
and other extensions you save it you'll
be able to see your new ad here here we
can see the ad we created okay notice
it's got the three headlines now this
has got the two descriptions and if I
want to add it I can just click edit add
and go ahead and edit it I don't want to
edit it then I don't have to I can
always go back so you can always edit it
out after it's been created okay if not
no big deal notice when you actually
create your ad in some cases Google's
going to review it to make sure it fits
within Google's guidelines and policies
but once it's approved you'll see it
under you'll see approved under the
status column and that's pretty much how
you would go ahead and create a text app
okay so when it does get approved it's
going to be in the rotation with the
other two ads and so what Google's going
to do is serve up each ad equally and
then eventually the ad that is
performing best will get served up more
and that way you're putting your best ad
always in front of the user who's
looking for the product and service
you're offering so now let's talk about
the metrics so associated with these
keywords these ads these ad groups and
campaigns so there are a lot of metrics
in Google ads a lot of metrics and we're
not even going to cover most of these
metrics we're just going to cover what I
deem the most common the most important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising whether that be on
Google search Network or Google's
Display Network you're going to have
some common metrics and here are the
metrics that we're going to focus on
today so you have Impressions cost
clicks average CPC conversions cost per
conversion CTR or click the rate and
quality score so let's go through these
metrics here and talk about what they
are so Impressions really it's the
number of times your ads been shown on
that particular Network whether it's
Google search or display and so an
impression is just how many times
somebody actually seen your ad okay
whether they actually physically seen it
or not if your ad is shown up on that
Network then an impression is going to
get counted so here for looking at ads
we can see we have over a period of time
certain amount of Impressions okay so
that's how many times this particular ad
has been shown so this particular ad
here the first one at the top has been
shown
557 times over this period of time which
is year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so so anytime your ad gets clicked
you're going to pay Google X amount so
if I go back to Google ads I can see
what my total cost is and not only can I
say what my total cost is I can see what
my average cost per click is and so
there's a lot of factors that go into
what you actually pay and some of these
factors are who else is advertising
where you're advertising what network
you're advertising on what time of day
what particular keyword and so there's a
lot of factors and so here I can see on
average year to date I've spent a dollar
eighty per click on this particular ad
for a total of
32.33 so I can really see how much I've
actually spent and so clicks is just
refers to how many times somebody
clicked on your ad so if your ads been
shown you need an impression and when
somebody sees your ad they're going to
click on your ad so the whole idea is to
get the click remember you want to be in
position additions one through three so
I want to make sure that my average
position is between one and three and so
if you're looking in Google ads at
metrics and you don't see average
position well you can always add that as
a column so if I click on columns here
and then I go to competitive metrics and
I click on average position and I'm
going to move average position all the
way to the top here so if I click move
average position all the way at the top
I'm going to be able to see what my
average position is over that particular
period of time so here I can see I'm in
positions one through three and that's
where you want to be you want to be in
positions one through three so if you're
in positions one through three that
means you're at the top if you're on
Google search or that means you're in a
problem position on the Display Network
so if your ad is shown meaning it gets
an impression then likely somebody's
going to click on that ad and if
somebody clicks on that ad it's going to
generate a click which in turn is going
to generate cost and so ideally what you
want to do is you want to measure the
rate at which people click on your ad
based on how many times it was shown so
here I can see 28 clicks over
3549 Impressions that's a 0.79 click
through rate so ideally the higher the
click-through rate the better the ad and
the higher the clicker rate the chances
are you're going to get more traffic to
your site so we want to be able to
measure clicks and we want to be able to
measure click-through rate and we also
want to measure cost per click which is
really the total cost divided by the
number of clicks so if I go back to
Google ads here I could see you know
17.57 over 28 clicks that averages it
out to about 63 cents per click so
that's how I get cost per click now your
cost per click is going to vary a little
bit okay so it's going to vary based on
keyword it's going to be based on where
you're advertising what position
Etc so there's a lot of factors involved
with cost per click but that's how you
would actually calculate it but Google
ads actually does a calculation for you
for collector rate and cost per click
but in case you want to know you can
always divide clicks into cost okay so
conversions probably one of the most
important metrics you're going to use in
Google ads because you're paying Google
and if you're paying Google for
advertising you want to make sure you're
getting return on your investment so
conversions are added when a user clicks
on your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something signing up for a newsletter
Etc so you want to make sure that if
you're in Google ads that you're
measuring conversions and so you simply
want to go to tools so if you go to
tools and then click on conversions you
want to make sure that you're running
conversions ideally what you want to do
is you want to run conversions from
Google analytics but you can certainly
see set up conversions within Google ads
as well notice I also have call from ads
as set up as a conversion so you have an
opportunity in Google ads to add a
number of different conversions and the
more conversions you add really the
better off you are because you want to
measure up all your campaigns against
conversions if I go back to campaigns I
want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions and if I can
measure that and I have a campaign
that's really driving conversions then
I'm going to continue to advertise on
Google okay so here over this particular
period of time I can see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at
128.67 cost per conversion and so how do
I get cost per conversion well I get my
total cost divided by the number of
conversions and then I can see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so really if I have 241 clicks
and nine conversions that's 9 divided by
241 that's 3.77 conversion rate so I can
measure conversion rate cost per
conversion and conversion just by
setting up conversions and Google ads
and so ideally if you're going to pay
Google for advertising you want to be
able to measure return on investment via
conversions so again seek cost per
conversion is just really then the total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then click the rate
again just as a reminder the total
clicks divided by the total number of
Impressions and then one other metric
we're going to talk about here today is
quality scores so quality score is
really Google's way of measuring how
well your keywords are are compared to
the ad associated with it the expected
click the rate and the landing page so
quality score is the backbone of Google
ads so if I go back to Google ads and I
click on keywords quality score is
something you want to measure and if you
don't have it in your columns you could
certainly just click on columns and add
it and so here I can see my quality
score and quality score is a measurement
between 1 and 10. and so if you have a
good quality score Google's gonna score
you higher because your keyword is
relevant to your ad it's relevant to the
landing page and you have a good
expected clicked array if you don't have
a good quality score Google is going to
let you know why you don't have a good
quality score so again your three
categories that make up quality score or
landing page experience which means
really Google looking at the landing
page or sending people to and they're
seeing if the page loads well fast does
it have ads does that have good content
is it good landing page will the end
user have a good experience they also
look at the ad relevance okay is the ad
relevant to the keyword and they'll also
look look at the expected click array
okay so based on other advertisers and
their click-through rate are you
achieving the same click-through rate
and so those three factors make up
quality score quality score is a metric
assigned to keywords so if you don't
have a good quality score you need to
fix it because the repercussion is
you're going to have to pay more so
having a good quality score likely means
you're going to pay less per click so
you want to make sure that if you bid on
a keyword that the keyword goes to a
relevant landing page the ad itself is
relevant and you're getting a good
click-through rate so quality score is
the backbone of Google ads and how it
works so you want to make sure you have
a good quality score so optimizing your
ads so what if you don't have a good
quality score what if you're not getting
conversions well there's things you can
do so remember we want to make sure that
we're add-in extensions whether that be
call site link review app add extensions
to your ads because it's going to
increase the click-through rate so you
can also really hone your ad copy if
you're selling products and you're
running promotion maybe you want to add
in a little sense of urgency to help
people you know realize hey if this this
promotion's ending maybe I want to click
on the ad and take action okay with
Google ads you can always run a b
testing on ads and so what you could do
is run two ads and one ad group and see
what ad is performing best in terms of
click-through rate or conversion rate
and whatever ad is running better you
can always run that ad and then continue
more testing so that way you're always
putting your best forward in terms of
advertising and the ad copy whether that
be text or display you always want to
use call to action you want to get
people to click on your ad when somebody
clicks on your ad it's going to to
improve click the array click the array
improves quality score so as I mentioned
several times already you want to make
sure your ads are placed at the top
between positions one and three on
Google search so you can measure add
position in Google ads and if you're not
ranked between one and three you want to
increase your bid okay you can also
optimize for local search so local is an
ad extension that you can add to your ad
you can also advertise at a time when
your audience is online or you can
advertise on during business hours only
so you can adjust when you advertise on
Google ensure some of your ads you know
capitalize on some particular events
that are related to your industry so you
can capitalize on that okay you can
certainly ask Google to accelerate your
ads okay or you can do standard delivery
so Google can spread out your clicks and
show your ads throughout the day Google
search is all about keywords so you want
to be able to pick and choose the right
keywords first you can also add negative
keywords so if you're bidding on a
specific industry let's just say you
have software and you want somebody to
sign up for your particular piece of
software but you don't offer a free
trial then maybe you want to add free as
a negative keyword so if you don't offer
anything for free free should be a
negative keyword so if somebody actually
does type in looking for free software
then your ad is not going to show up so
that's the whole idea behind negative
keywords okay you can use Dynamic
keyword insertion into your ads meaning
you can ask Google hey I'm on to
dynamically insert a keyword into my ad
that somebody uses to make your ad more
relevant so relevancy increases
click-through rate and improves quality
score so as you can see there's a lot of
things you can do here's some more
things you can use brand and keywords
words you can use particular match types
in Google so let's talk about match ties
for a second so you have different match
types if I go back to Google ads here I
could see my keywords that I'm bidding
on so by default if you actually bid on
a keyword it's going to be broad match
and so if I've been on the keyboard
medical computer is somebody typed in
something related to medical and
included the keyword Medical but not
computer then my ad May show up however
I can make an exact match so somebody
can type in exactly only medical
computers so if I click edit and I can
change the match type for that
particular keyword to exact then that
means that somebody that types in only
medical computer my ad is going to show
up I can basically do phrase match so
somebody types in looking for something
that's going to help me with medical
computers okay that's a long tail phrase
work keyword query but the query word
medical computer is in that order so my
ad is going to show up okay so with
phrase match your ad is going to show
when somebody types in that keyword
you're bidding on in that order you also
have broad match modifier so if you have
a plus sign in front of the keyword then
that means that somebody actually has to
use that keyword in the query in order
for your ad to show up okay so you could
change the match type of any keyword so
if you use an x-active phrase then
chances are you're going to have lower
volume of queries but probably higher
relevancy if you use a broad match then
your ad could show up for any
combination of search queries so you
really want to be careful on the match
type that you choose so keep an eye on
quality score remember Google has
quality score between one and ten the
higher quality score the better you are
so really if you have a quality score I
would say anything below of four you
probably want to pause the keyword okay
so you can measure quality score at the
keyword level so if I go back to Google
ads and I have keywords that are say
three chances are I'm going to have to
pay more for the click and it might not
be worth it so I may want to end up
pausing that keyword and try other
keywords that are more relevant that I
can send traffic to when we're rolling
landing page or I can have an ad that's
more relevant to that keyword in order
to help with the quality score okay you
can ensure that your landing pages are
mobile friendly so that's another thing
you want to keep in mind that most
people start their search on mobile so
you certainly want to make sure that
your landing pages are optimized because
if somebody starts to search on mobile
likes your products or service chances
are they're coming back via desktop or
even going into the store most searches
start on mobile so you want to make sure
those pages are optimized and there's
plenty more things you could do to
optimize your ads you want to make sure
you group and organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write relevant ads for those
keywords so if I go back to Google ads I
want to make sure if I go to add groups
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another so what's my
ad group name well if it's medical PC if
I click on medical PC I want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to Medical PC I want to
structure my campaigns and AD groups to
Target more ads effectively so you want
to be able to you know organize your
campaigns and AD groups and the rule of
thumb here is you should organize your
campaigns and AD groups based on the
site architecture of your site so the
way your website is laid out in the
navigation is how you should likely
structure your campaigns and groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to campaigns that are
converting okay you can use automatic
bidding for ads to maximize results so
meaning that Google has what they call
artificial intelligence so Google can do
a lot of the bidding and a lot of the
managing for you that's really a great
benefit to running your ads on Google so
their machines are learning behavior
from your keywords that you're bidding
on and so ideally when they learn what's
converting they're going to bid more and
try and help you get the conversion for
the keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that Google ads has to offer in order to
improve performance
now Google is the dominant search engine
on the web customers turn to Google when
they want to find information about
products and services that means people
are actively seeking information to show
your ads to active Searchers or people
looking for your products and services
you can use Google ads which is Google's
advertising program
in this lesson you'll learn how Google
ads connects your business with
customers so you can reach your
marketing goals now by the end of this
lesson you'll be able to understand how
Google ADS works discuss the various
targeting methods and know the primary
benefits of using Google ads
that lets you connect your business with
prospective customers so for instance
let's say someone has a broken pipe in
their house and they want to find a
local plumber they often turn to Google
to search for their answers now if
you're buying a new house you might
search for Real Estate or mortgages or
moving companies all of these are
searches that someone conducts every day
so to reach these Searchers you can use
Google ads now Google ads is a complex
system made up of multiple networks
targeting options ad formats budget
management and so forth so we need to
take a look at how the system works to
ensure you're targeting the users who
can turn into customers
now it starts with picking targeting
methods this could be a user searching
for a keyword in a specific geography on
a specific device and operating systems
so it will get more into targeting
methods as we go through our lessons so
you can write effective ads for those
targeting methods you set a bid for how
much you're willing to pay if someone
clicks on your ad now when someone does
a search and it matches your targeting
method then your ad can be displayed so
if the user looks your ad and says yep
that's what I'm looking for and the user
clicks on the ad they go to your site
now at that moment is when you pay for
the click
or for any action that can happen from
an ad directly such as calling your
company now once users click in your ads
they go to your site if they take an
action such as calling your company or
buying a product or filling out a form
or just watching a video then you can
measure those actions now this lets you
see your data for each targeting method
keyword and add data to understand how
each is performing now we'll Define this
information as we go through our lessons
so you know what to look for to make
data-driven decisions then from those
data driven decisions you can refine
your targeting methods test different
ads and set appropriate bids based upon
how each click or interaction is worth
to your business let's say that you're a
plumbing company and you're only in
Houston Texas so you could Target only
Houston Texas with keywords such as
broken pipes remodeling kitchen and
other services that you conduct then for
each of those keywords you write an ad
and set a bid if someone is searching
from within Houston for kitchen
remodeling they could see your ad so if
they were searching from Austin or
California or Seattle and they're not in
your targeting method they can't see
your ad so it's important to think about
where are your customers how are they
searching and then make sure your ads
are compelling and then you can turn
those Searchers into your next customers
now the first network is known as search
this is when someone inputs a keyword or
a search query into a search engine and
then sees results there's more than 167
billion searches a month
now then there's another Network that
Google also supports known as the
Display Network these are non-certs
places that can show ads so Google
Display Network is made up of more than
3 million websites and apps that
Encompass more than one trillion
Impressions a month now these ad
placements could be apps in your phone
or a newspaper publisher site with so
many possible ad displays you're
targeting methods help narrow down when
your ad is displayed so you can ensure
only those who you want to see your ad
will see your ad
the three primary targeting methods to
think about initially are location time
of day or day of the week and device the
location is where our ads are going to
be displayed this could be every country
in the world it could be a single state
it could be 10 states it could be a
radius around your business or your PIN
code you have a lot of control and
options over location targeting and next
we have time of day and this could be
time of day or even just day of the week
so let's say you have a call center
that's only open from nine to five
Monday to Friday then you could run your
ads only during those times nine to five
Monday to Friday now most companies run
their ads all the time but you can
adjust when they do run there are other
considerations such as you're a small
business where you really only answer
your phone from eight to four so you
could only run your ads during that time
now if you're a restaurant you might
want to run your ads later in the
evening to take reservations you can
also choose the device and operating
systems where you want your ads to run
such as mobile devices tablets computers
or all three so for example if you're a
pizza delivery place most pizza orders
are now on mobile devices so while you
may be on all devices mobile is your
primary one then you pick your location
based upon your delivery area and then
finally you choose the time of day for
when your business is open and actively
delivering pizzas now if you're a large
SAS company and you're International
your locations might be worldwide so you
want to think about breaking down our
ads and keywords by languages or regions
so we'll get more into how these
breakdowns occur in the account but a
location could be worldwide our time of
day is 24 7 and our devices are just all
devices so you have a lot of control of
your targeting methods and how people
can see your ads both when and where
keyword is an object you put into your
Google ads account now a search term or
search query is what a user types into a
search engine to see results so in this
search term matches your keyword then
your ad can be displayed so if you're a
modeling company and you do kitchens and
bathrooms and room additions but maybe
you don't do basements you could pick
kitchen modeling keywords and bathroom
modeling keywords but ignore basement
keywords because you don't do that type
of remodeling work now you can also
choose demographics such as age gender
and income level if you're a high-end
art dealer you might only sell the top
30 percent of income levels if you're
selling female only clothing then you
could Target just females now in
addition we can do things like
behavioral targeting which is based upon
how people use our websites this is
sometimes known as remarketing if
someone came to your site and they added
items to a shopping cart but they didn't
check out we know they're almost ready
to buy therefore you could Target those
users differently than someone who's
never been to your website let's say a
user searches for accounting services on
Google in Maryland in the US anytime
during the week they could see an ad for
a local Maryland accountant let's say
you're on a call center for mortgage
leads and you're only open on the
weekdays then you could run your ad for
the entire country only during Monday to
Friday during the hours your call
centers open and only show an ad if
someone searches for mortgage rates
mortgage quotes and so forth so as we
think about our targeting it's where our
customers are located what they are
looking for the devices they are on and
the types of people we want to serve ads
to
now Google ads is an auction based
system you set a bid based upon what you
believe a click is worth to you and then
Google looks at your bid and the
relevancy of your ads and they do this
for all the other advertisers as well
then they order the ads in this search
results were cross-display properties
based upon both the bid and the
relevancy now this is an important
consideration as useful ads are as
important as your bids in determining
position so we'll get into this later
when we look at organization now it's
not just who bids the most that will get
you into position one is your ad
relevant to the user there's a lot of
ways to make things relevant and we'll
walk through this later if a user sees
your ad you don't pay anything only if a
user clicks on your ad do you pay the
search engine that's why it's called pay
per click advertising is the only hey
when someone clicks on the ad now you
can then measure results such as
acquired customers return on ad spend
revenue and so forth now based upon the
results you're receiving from Google ads
you can then refine your ads or change
your bids based upon what those clicks
are worth to you
when we think about the Google ads
benefits we often call them the three
R's reach relevance Roi now from a reach
standpoint Google search and the display
networks have tremendous reach they can
help you reach your target audience
because your target audience is probably
using Google whether it's on search or
display or both so the advertising
system has the reach that encompasses
your potential customers the next think
about relevance this is a big thing in
advertising are you relevant to the
users right searches are often resistant
and that's why if you're watching TV in
a commercial appears you might hit the
fast forward button or switch the
channel when the ad is relevant users
like ads they'll interact with them if
they're useful and they're relevant so
you can Target users based upon many
criteria which means your ad should be
relevant to you users especially on
search when you pick keywords that
represent your business as someone is
actively searching for that word that
means they're looking for a solution so
when users see relevant ads they're more
likely to click and do business with
your company now finally we have Roi
known as return on investment as our
third benefit return ad spend rowas or
Roi let us know how profitable a channel
is now as you can measure results from
your ad spend you can make data-driven
decisions based upon how users interact
with your ads and how they're becoming
customers so Google ads has the reach
that encompasses your users when you
make good accounts and you have good
account structure which we'll get into
later videos you can ensure your ad is
relevant to users so if I'll click on
the ads
and come to your website so you can turn
them into customers now with analytics
and conversion tracking you can see
exactly how much that person's worth to
you so then you can adjust your reach
and your relevance data to ensure that
your return investment is fantastic from
using Google ads as a marketing channel
so Google ads accounts have multiple
levels of structure in order for you to
be able to control how users can view
interact with your ads along with your
budget and bid controls now in this
lesson we'll examine each low of
hierarchy so you can understand how
average accounts fit together and how
data flows throughout your account so by
the end of this lesson you'll be able to
understand account level settings
understand campaign targeting options
and discuss the purpose of an ad group
so when we look at the overall account
hierarchy it starts where we have an
account then an account can be made of
one or more campaigns then each campaign
can have one or more ad groups and then
finally ad groups are a collection of
ads and keywords so as we look at
accounts campaigns and AD groups each
level has different items you set with
it so we're going to look individually
at each of these items to see how you
can use various settings at each level
now at the account level we have several
options that we can set the first is
account access this is who can log in
and access your data so when you open an
account you use a Google account the
list doesn't have to be a Gmail address
you can make your own email address for
your company a Google account and then
use that for login purposes but then you
can give others access to your account
as well from a security standpoint it's
useful just to have one administrator
who gives access levels to other
individuals that way if someone leaves
your company or no longer needs access
to your data you can disable just that
access point instead of using shared
account logins now you'll also choose
your time zone now some items such as
time zone and currency cannot be changed
once you open the account so your pick
your time zone and when you think about
it you it's useful to have your
analytics your server and your marketing
such as your Google ads account on the
same time zone now because if you've got
inside's account in Pacific time and
your servers on Eastern time there's a
three hour period of time a day when
your data doesn't agree with each other
so it's useful to sync servers Google
ads account analytics so forth into a
single time zone now you'll also choose
your currency do you want to be billed
in Euros or dollars or Pounds or
Canadian dollars and so forth again
currency can't be changed once you've
set up your account as well and then you
have billing how are you going to pay
for the clicks that you accrue and then
you can connect other accounts to your
Google ads account such as Google
analytics Google merchant center
Firebase Etc so if you're using multiple
systems you can connect them all
together at the account level so they
can all use the same data and then you
have notification settings how do you
want to be notified of suggestions or
disapproved ads and so forth in some
preferences like display language number
formats Etc so that when you open an
account the two most important options
really to think about though are time
zone and currency they can't be changed
you can change your billing later on or
you can change who has account access
some preferences but time zone and
currency are set once your account is
open let's look at the campaign settings
you'll have an account an account can be
made up of one or more campaigns so a
campaign setting is where you're going
to tell Google Google ads how to show
the ads and keywords within that
campaign so first we have the network do
you want to be on search Network Display
Network or potentially both and when
you're first starting search is the best
place to start because users are
actively looking for Solutions so you
could have one campaign that search and
another campaign that is display now we
choose our devices at the campaign level
as well so might be on all devices we
could be on just mobile devices or just
computers or just tablets if we want to
run our ads at certain times of day or
day of the week we also set those and
the campaign settings so if you only
want your ads to run Monday to Friday
you can choose those options at the
campaign level now is say you want your
brand terms to run all the time and then
you have other keywords you only want to
run Monday to Friday then you can use
two campaigns campaigns can have
different settings from each other so
you could have one campaign for your
leads on keywords that runs Monday to
Friday clicks go to a call center you
can maybe have another campaign that's
brand terms that runs all seven days of
the week and they're in another campaign
so that way you can segment out which
items run when now locations are also
set up at the campaign setting so if
you're a multi-location business you've
got one location on Houston another in
Seattle another in New York and you only
want to run ads in those geographies you
could either put one campaign together
and Target all three of those locations
then go campaign now all those locations
would use the same ads and keywords or
you can make a campaign for each
location and if you make a campaign by
location then any other settings such as
time a day or budgets which use campaign
settings can be customized for each
location your bid method is also a cam
campaign setting so with bid Methods at
a high level there's two types one's
manual where you set the bid yourself
and another is automated where you're
setting a goal for the system and the
system is bidding on your behalf and
then you have budget how much you're
willing to spend on a daily basis so if
you have one location and you want to
spend a hundred dollars a day and then
you have another location where you want
to spend 500 a day that would be two
different campaigns so you can have
different budgets for each of the
campaigns so when you want a campaign
level setting to be different for some
reason a set of keywords location or
something else that's one of the reasons
to make a different campaign so if you
want certain ads to run only in certain
locations only certain times a day if
you have budgets by product line you use
different campaigns to control those
items so when you think about budget
management if you want on a different
budget by product line you make each
product line its own campaign so when we
think about search here's a couple
examples of how we might set up
campaigns might have one campaign is on
search it's on all devices it's only set
to the country of say the United States
it uses an automated bid system that can
spend a hundred dollars a day you might
have another campaign it's on search
it's only on desktops it's set to France
it's based on manual bidding it has a
fifty dollar a day budget so when you
want these campaign level settings to be
different that's one of the main reasons
to create a new campaign for the ads and
keywords that are inside of that
campaign
now ad groups are a collection of
keywords and ads and only an ad from
that ad group that contains the same
keyword that matched to a search query
right can be displayed so ad groups
should be closely related collections of
keywords and ads so we think about the
work involved in setting up a Google ads
account it's really quick just to make
an account it can be very quick to make
a campaign but where you're going to
slow down and spend your time is
thinking about your ad groups someone
did a search they are looking for
something they're gonna then see an ad
so that ad is going to take them to a
page of your website so you want that
user experience be very cohesive so you
may have one campaign the campaign could
have 20 or 50 or a thousand AG groups in
it right for each type of idea that
you're advertising so if you want to
show a user a different ad based upon
their search term changing you want a
different ad group
let's say we sell shoes now we sell
hiking boots we sell running shoes we
sell dress shoes now we don't want to do
is put all of those in one ad group
because if someone searches for hiking
boots versus a running shoe versus a
dress shoe you want a different ad
there's not a good ad explains all those
Concepts so we could write and add shoes
for sale right but shoes for sale
doesn't really speak to the user if
someone's doing a search for hiking
boots right and they see an ad that says
shoes for sale and another ad that says
hiking boots for sale right walk on the
trails comfortably right they're gonna
look at the one that says shoes for sale
and say it's not relevant to what I'm
looking for and the ad that mentioned
the product they search for hiking boots
would be relevant we get a lot more of
those clicks and conversions so why we
may take some keywords like hiking boots
Trail hiking boots hiking boots for sale
our best hiking boots and put them in an
AG group together right we make an ad
only for those keywords so we create an
ad hiking boots for sale walk the trails
in Comfort but then someone searches for
running shoes that ad would not be a
good result for them right hiking boots
and AD that they're looking for running
shoes so you'd want a different ad group
for running shoes so you might have
keywords running shoes best running
shoes shoes for running marathon long
distance running shoes right and then we
can make an ad that says running shoes
for sale maximize your performance now
if we really focused on running shoes
and that was our Core Business then we
wouldn't want to run just the running
shoe ad because that's very general we
want to get more specific if someone's
running a marathon they want long
distance running shoes others want
minimalistic running shoes you'll see
see people search for running shoes with
high arches is or better Arc support
white box shoes since you can even get
into those very specific terms to create
ads for them in the ad groups when you
think about ad group structure only the
keywords and that ad group can show for
that ad right if we have two ad groups
and someone searches for running shoes
right they can't see our hiking boots ad
because it's in a different aggregate
only so the running shoes at so you can
make multiple ads in an ad group and do
some ad testing to see which is best so
if we look at an ad group and we see
here's another keyword that we really
want to look at and the ads we have
aren't great for that keyword we can
move it to a new ad group so we may have
one ad groups that stress shoes another
for high heels and we can make new
aggers for all of these items so that
the ad and then where the user goes on
your website or Is specific to each of
those types that idea of keywords so you
might have many aggers but the trick
about ad groups is you have a core set
of keywords in each ad group and then
you have multiple ads in an Aggregate
and so as long as all the ads and the
keywords are reflective of each other
then you've got a good ad group now if
an ad does not represent a keyword that
keyword should be in a different anger
settings are inherited downwards across
the account so for instance the account
level you set billing the billing method
is used by all the campaigns in the
account and all the ad groups so you set
access level by account so anyone with
account access level can see are your
campaigns in ad groups so then at the
campaign level we enter settings like
budgets location so that goes to the
campaign level is inherited down to the
ad groups so any AD group in the
campaign that can show to all the users
and a location that set at the campaign
level or budgets and so forth so then
that goes from campaign is inherited to
the ad groups so any AD group in the
campaign can show where it may reach the
campaign setting such as location or it
uses that same budget right all the ad
groups on campaign use a budget so if we
have different campaigns then only the
ad groups in that campaign would use
that campaign's budget and that
campaign's targeting method so when you
create create a setting at the account
level it's used at the campaign level
and then anything at the campaign level
is used at the ad group level so if you
create ad group level settings for
something you can set up the ad group
they're only used by the ads and
keywords in that specific ad group AD
group data is never inherited to another
ad group so setting hierarchy flows
downwards across the account from
account to campaign to ad group and then
the ads and keywords
so the first step to getting started
with Google ads is opening an account
now once you open an account then you
can fill in your billing information add
additional users and connect your
analytics account to your Google ads
account
so in this lesson we will look at how to
create the initial account
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to open a Google ads account set
permission levels and user access data
and then connect additional accounts now
before you begin creating a Google ads
account you'll need a Google account to
access it if you use Gmail then you can
use your Gmail account if you want to
use your business email then you can
create an account and use your business
email address you'll need to verify your
account through a text message code or
through an email to the email address
you're using access your Google ads
account now once you've established how
to access your Google ads account
proceed to setting up your first
campaign each person who can access your
data should have their own login this
lets you choose their permission level
remove someone when they should no
longer have access and see what changes
were made in the change history tool
which logs changes by user access before
adding a user you should consider the
permission level that the user needs so
for instance if you want someone to see
information but not change anything you
can give them read only access if you
want a user to be able to make any
changes but not add or move other users
they can have standard access by giving
each user access you can maintain
control over your data and also add and
remove other users as your need for
accessing your data changes
there are times when you all want your
Google ads account to connect with other
applications so they can share data back
and forth this is really common with
Google analytics by connecting Google
analytics and Google ads you can see a
lot of data in both places in addition
you can create conversions or audience
lists in Google analytics and have them
imported into Google ads if you're an
e-commerce company then you want to
create a Google merchant center account
and Link it to your Google ads account
so you can create shopping campaigns a
common problem you might come across is
that one email is the admin for one
account and another email is the admin
for your Google ads account you might
need to give someone permission to log
into Google ads to connect accounts well
they might need to give you permission
to access the accounts that you want to
link to Google ads so you have the
necessary permission low levels in both
places to connect the data once you have
the necessary permissions in place it's
easy to connect other accounts to your
Google ads account using the linked
accounts tool inside of your Google ads
account so I want you to imagine having
the world at your fingertips especially
when it comes to advertising imagine
having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising so just
imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to any website in
the world can you imagine that well
imagine having that entirety at your
fingertips the entire world so it's not
really an imagination so no need to
imagine anymore because Google ads has
come to the rescue so no need to imagine
the world is at your fingertips and why
is it at your fingertips because of
Google and specifically Google Display
Network work okay so we're gonna talk
about what the Google Display Network is
so let's start out by asking the
question or answering the question what
is the Google Display Network so Google
has two networks basically one the
search Network one the Display Network
so you as an Advertiser if you want to
advertise on Google you have a choice
can I go with Google search or can I go
with the Display Network well the search
Network is for Google search only so if
you want to advertise when somebody
types in a keyword query and you want
your ad to show up that's the search
Network so it looks something like this
somebody types in a keyword data science
and lo and behold ads show up and here
you can see the first ad from Simply
learn why did that ad show up because
simply Learned was bidding on the
keyword data science and so that's how
the search network works you bid on
keywords somebody Types on those
keywords and your ads show up and the
search engine results at the top above
organic listings so that's the search
Network and it just simply comprises of
ads that respond to what people are
querying okay the display network is a
little bit different so that's the
search Network today we're going to talk
about the Display Network okay the
display network is a little bit
different so imagine you're on the
lookout for a new shoe on Amazon as an
example but you don't have end up buying
the shoe you're looking at shoes you
don't buy it well you might have noticed
in the past you've done something like
that whether it be shoes or shirts or
coats or belts or cars or radios or
headphones or phones it doesn't really
matter you might have been looking at
something and then notice an ad show up
it might have been exactly that same
product or might have been something
similar to the product you were looking
at but on the same website so why does
that happen well it happened happens
because Google's Display Network
specifically remarketing which we'll
talk about so on Google's Display
Network you have the option to advertise
as somebody's been on your website so
that's one of the powers and one of the
features of Google's Display Network and
that's remarketing or retargeting
somebody that's looked at your product
so let's take a little bit of a deeper
dive into how the display network works
so if you're a customer you go to a
website and you leave that website again
from a remarketing perspective your
product can appear on another site okay
so that's remarketing so you can
retarget that person who's been to your
site so that's again one great example
of how to use Display Network in Google
terms and call it remarketing and again
somebody goes to your website they leave
in this example not buying something it
could be a technology company where we
want somebody to watch a video or
download a a PDF okay whatever they do
that that you want them to do but they
don't actually do it then you can go
back and retarget them so if they
actually go to a page and look at your
product but don't buy that product then
you have the opportunity to advertise to
them again so the whole idea is if you
advertise them again wow that person can
say okay I remember that I was in still
interested in that product let me go
back and purchase that product so they
go back to the site and make the
purchase so that's again the power of
the Display Network you can reach people
who have been to your site before so
let's take another look here it's a
retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code or pixel on your website
which uses browsercookies to add website
visitors to your audience so let me just
summarize that for you so if you want to
use Display Network and you want to
Target people who've been to your
website well you need to add a simple
script or pixel if you will to your
website that's all and so when somebody
comes to your website they're gonna get
cookied and that cookie is stored in
their browser and so that's an import
important piece of the whole process
because that's how Google determines who
that visitor is so without that cookie
then Google won't know to show their ad
your ad to them again so that's the
first piece in all this so when somebody
does get cookied they're going to be
added to that audience and so when we
say audience we mean you as an
Advertiser to finding who you want to
retarget to so in this example we're
talking about people who have looked at
a product and didn't purchased that
could be a whole audience in itself
people who look at a product and don't
purchase it could be everyone who comes
to your website it could be only
returning users it could be only new
users you define the audience but
however you define that audience they're
going to get cookied and placed on a
list and when they're placed in that
list they're going to get shown the ad
again so past visitors will see your
product ads when they're browsing the
web watching videos on YouTube going
through news sites and so on so if
that's your audience list past visitors
that's where are they going to be able
to see your ad because Google's Display
Network is much more than just websites
it's also YouTube it's also news feeds
it's also social networking sites so
there's a lot involved with Google's
Display Network so the network involves
several websites that are partnered up
with Google along with the likes of
YouTube along with the likes and
millions of other websites in fact these
websites together tally up to more than
2 million that encompasses more than 90
percent of the internet so you can
imagine Google's Display Network is just
made up of a bunch of websites including
YouTube okay so you have the opportunity
to really reach somebody that's been to
your website before so again if they're
past visitors and they looked at a
product and they didn't purchase it you
have an opportunity to really put your
ad in front of them on a lot of
different websites so that's just an
intro about the display network
remarketing is just one benefit but
let's take a step back so we dove into
the deep end with remarketing let's just
separate out the two again just so
you're clear on what the display network
is versus the search Network well let's
go some through some of the differences
so Display Network on the left search
Network on the right so the Display
Network as we just discussed is great
for retargeting people who have been to
your website whether they're new users
returning users users who looked at a
product users who added a product to
your cart users who looked at a specific
page whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network is
usually for top of funnel why do we say
top of funnel because users are actively
searching for something they're looking
for a product they're being active so
they're going to search and seeing who
has that product okay the Display
Network we know remarketing is a benefit
but usually it's bottom of funnel like
brand awareness so if nobody knows who
your brand is is what your brand is or
what you have to offer what your
services are then the Display Network
remember made up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display bottom of
funnel search Network top of funnel
somebody actively looking for something
let's take a look at some other
differences here so Display Network
easier to advertise products that don't
satisfy an immediate need this is true
because again if you have a new product
you want to get that product out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least they're going to
know what the product's about on the
search Network on the other hand if
somebody's looking for something like a
particular product that you're offering
then they can type in a keyword that
describes that product in Wham your ad
can appear at the top okay remember top
of funnel so products and services
usually fulfill a particular requirement
now the Display Network can be used to
familiarize users to your brand so again
going back to remarketing somebody comes
to your website they really don't know
who you are well you can reach back out
to them on the Display Network with
another ad retargeting and that's how
you can get users familiar with your
brand we're on the search Network users
are shown ads based on what they search
for so it doesn't really matter if they
know your brand or not hey if they're
looking for something then they're ready
to buy and you have that product at the
right price then the chance of them
converting are pretty good so you're at
the right place at the right time where
the display Network's all about
familiarity retargeting of people with
your brand getting your brand out there
getting your product out there in front
of millions of people now on the Display
Network users are shown these ads in
over a million different websites so
with the Display Network you have the
opportunity to kind of hone in and pick
and choose those websites we're on the
search Network users are shown ads in
Google apps and on the search engines so
you have the opportunity to place your
ads not just on desktop search but also
on mobile and also on apps whereas again
the display network is made up of much
more it's made up of websites YouTube
apps Etc okay the display network has a
multitude of different formats okay when
we say different formats we mean text
ads image ads rich media ads meaning ads
that have some functionality to it like
movement okay and then video ads where
the search network is really only text
ads and I say really only text ads where
you can have image ads those are called
shopping ads but mainly it's text ads
where Display Network you have an option
between text image rich media or Video
Edit so you can see the differences here
really there are big differences between
the two networks where search you're
just really responding what somebody's
looking for they're really active and
ready to go display hey you're trying to
reach out to these people you're trying
to introduce them to some something and
in some cases with remarketing you're
reaching out to them again okay you're
trying to get them familiar with your
product and brand and you're trying to
do that via video via rich media via
regular image ad via text ad so you're
trying to do it in a multitude of
formats so again bottom of funnel for
display top of funnel for search so
that's an intro to the Display Network
those are the differences between search
and display now let's go through the
steps of how to set up a campaign in
Google ads using the Display Network as
our option so here I am I'm in Google
ads I'm in an account and I want to set
up a campaign on the Display Network so
you can see here if I'm in Google ads
I've selected display campaigns I can
already see I have some Display Network
campaign set up in fact they're all
remarketing campaigns and so remarketing
remember it's targeting somebody who
fits a list or just description okay so
it could be somebody looking at a
particular product they get cookied
meaning that text file is going to sit
on their browser and then they're gonna
see your ad the next time they're on
Google's Display Network wherever site
they may be so we're reaching out to
somebody who fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display campaign meaning a
campaign on Google's Display Network we
want to go to campaigns and we want to
click on the plus button here and we're
just going to say new campaign now we
have the opportunity now to pick and
choose what our goal is for that
campaign and so most the time with
display you're going to choose brand
awareness and reach okay so here you can
see the campaign types for brand
awareness and reach display and video
usually when it comes to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search network but if
you're just really trying to just
promote your brand you may go with
display because remember you have the
option to get your ad in front of
millions of websites we're going to
choose brand awareness and reach okay
and we're going to choose the campaign
type so here you have display we want to
run different kinds of ads or we can run
just video okay we want to run if we're
running video we can reach and engage
viewers on YouTube and across the web
meaning other websites okay which shoes
display here so we're going to go ahead
and just put our website in there so our
businesses website
and when that loads up we're going to
have a number of different options
available to us so here we can name our
campaign okay so here you can see brand
awareness and reach is the name of our
campaign and for now we're just gonna
contest now we have the opportunity to
choose our location here we're going to
choose the United States we have just
like a search campaign we also have
language as an option so with search you
have locations and languages same thing
on display so we're going to Target
English as our language and what are we
trying to do what are we focusing on
well we want to get our product out
there so we're going to choose
Impressions viewable Impressions that's
really what we want to focus on we want
people to see our ad okay it's an
impression is the number of times
somebody sees your ad okay so we have
viewable Impressions that's what we want
people to do we want them to see our ad
and if you take a peek over here on the
right side you can see your targeting's
reach so we can reach over 10 billion
million plus in Impressions meaning
that's a lot of eyeballs the number of
people looking at our ad right now is
over 10 billion plus okay so that's just
gives you the scope and some idea of how
big Google's Display Network is so just
like search we could set a budget I'm
just going to choose a hundred dollars
for now and I can choose how to deliver
that budget just like on search I have
standard accelerated I can ask Google to
speed up the spend or I could just do
regular standard which means they're
going to spend my budget evenly over a
period of time over the course of the
day now remember with Display Network we
have different options on ad types we
have text ads rich media ads regular
image ads and video so we can rotate our
ads how we like so we could say hey look
I want to run my best performing ads
okay so that means I want Google to
optimize for me meaning if I have an ad
that's performing better than some
others then I'm going want to let Google
run that one more and that's the one I
would recommend but you do have other
options here you can just have them
rotate evenly you could say hey optimize
for conversions but it's really remember
our goal here for display is to get
impressions eyeballs we're not
interested in top of funnel conversions
in here we could say rotate evenly and
that's not supported for display so
really our best option here is prefer
best performing ads we want our best
performing ads to run okay we have an
option to schedule them we have an
option to start and okay and we have an
option to set a cap how many times we
want somebody to look at that ad so we
can limit how many times our ad is shown
to the same user okay so we're gonna let
Google optimize how often your ads are
shown however we do have the option to
set that limit okay so we could set the
limit to x times per day for the entire
campaign or it could be for a particular
ad or ad group okay so we could set the
limiter sounds and we can let Google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions okay and then we have the
opportunity to set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
Network the ad group on display is where
your settings are going to be your ads
are going to be located in your ad group
and now the important part we want to
get to audiences so if we're remarketing
we're going to choose our audience and
if we're not remarketing we still have
the opportunity to choose our audience
so if I'm a tech company and I just type
in Tech then Google's going to give me
some options here so here I can choose
some tech companies technology products
new inventions
Etc or I can choose some ideas that
Google has in mind for audiences like
they have an in-market audience so this
is based on network system and Services
Network management so the bottom line is
Google is giving me suggestions on who I
can Target my ad to okay that's what
really what this is choosing your
audience now you don't have to choose
anything here in fact you can just clear
all and be done with it now you can go
down to demographics now I could pick
and choose based on gender I could pick
and choose based on age parental status
and household income really depending on
who you're advertising to that's really
what it comes down to it okay so you
have demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of Google's
recommended audiences or you can create
your own audience okay and we're going
to talk about that here in a minute but
this is all part of the setup for the
campaign so I'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you can set up a
bid just like you went on the search
Network and then you have the option to
choose your ad so that's part of the
campaign setup so when you actually
choose your ad again you have different
options image ad okay rich media ad
video or text once you choose your ad
then you pretty much have your campaign
set up now we're gonna tweak it after we
set it up but that's pretty much the
steps and terms of setting up a display
campaign very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience and choosing the ad type
that's really the main differences
between setting up a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones so we talked about remarketing
to people who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they looked at a product or they
looked at a particular page so if you're
going to retarget the people then as a
best practice I would set up the
audience in Google analytics so Google
analytics talks to Google ads in fact
you can link link up to in analytics so
regardless of whether you're creating a
display campaign or search campaign you
want to link up analytics with Google
ads so you can see we've done that here
okay now that we've linked the two up we
could set up an audience in Google
analytics for use on a remarketing
campaign on Google's Display Network so
here you can see I have audiences set up
if you want to just create a new
audience you can do that so if I click
new audience here here I can choose
choose returning users or new users
these are audiences that Google has set
up by default I can create a new one if
I want so I could say hey I want to
Target you know 18 to 24 year old males
who speak English for example
and who came from mobile so if I go here
technology I'm going to say including
mobile so that could be my audience so
anybody who fits that description of 18
to 24 year old coming to my website from
mobile who speaks English I'm going to
retarget them and you can go ahead and
save this so if I go ahead and click
apply I'm going to name my audience 18
24 year old male English mobile one
thing about remarketing on the display
network is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live so
depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car the funnel maybe six months
long if they're buying a pair of shoes
then the funnel may be seven days long
maybe even shorter so really depends on
your business the default is 30 days so
if you go with 30 days and that means
any 18 to 24 year old male who speaks
English and comes from mobile is going
to get cookied and that cookie is going
to live for 30 days so if I click next
step I can go ahead and publish it I can
say I want this to be available in my
Google ads account so I'm going to go
ahead and pick my account and it'll be
available in that account so I'll choose
my account and then go ahead and click
publish so now this audience list is
going to be available for me to use in
my display campaign when I go to choose
my audience so if I go back to Google
ads so Google ads and Google analytics
talk to one another why because they're
linked and so now when I go to actually
set up my ad group and I'm choosing
remarketing I can go ahead and choose
that audience list so for example this
campaign that's already set up I can go
ahead and choose to set up another ad
group with that particular audience list
so if I choose new ad group and now I'm
going to search for the audience I just
set up so here you go I just did a
search and here's my audience I'm going
to select my audience and I'm going to
now use this audience in my ad group for
my remarketing campaign so now all I
need to do is align find the right ad
with this audience so that's how
remarketing works you choose your
audience list you set up your ads
remember you have different ad formats
video rich media image and text and the
whole idea Beyond remarketing is you
know who your audience is you know what
you want to say to them so your ads
should really Encompass that message the
message of what you want to say to that
particular group in this case 18 to 24
year old male who speak English who came
to your site from mobile so if you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the Display Network to your
advantage remember bottom of the funnel
the goal of our campaign is just get our
ad out there so that people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go to set up an ad
group you don't have to choose an
audience to retarget to you do have
other options so if I look at this group
here you can see I have image ads
already set up so where do I want these
image ads to appear so I do have options
available to me in the Display Network
so if I choose keywords then that means
if I go ahead and add a keyword then
what Google is going to do is
contextually place my image ad on a
website that fits the description or
matches that keyword so if I add one or
two or three keywords then what Google's
going to do is going to look at that
keyword and it's going to map a website
on the display network using those
keywords so that's keywords now you got
to be careful here because it's a broad
way of advertising meaning your ads
could appear on sites that you don't
necessarily deem relevant to those
keywords so you're allowing Google to
match the the website with the keywords
you choose so that's choosing keywords
audiences again audiences are there if
you want to retarget so if you're
retargeting you can set up your audience
in analytics in fact that's the best
practice so again if I go back to
analytics and I go back to admin under
my property audiences I can go ahead and
choose my audience to be used in Google
ads so that's using audiences on a
display campaign on Google's Display
Network when we're setting up our
campaign we had an option to choose
demographics so we can exclude a
demographic if we wanted to we can
always go back and exclude a demographic
just by removing them from the ad group
notice if we choose all demographics we
can actually then see over a period of
time in Google ads how many people based
on this particular age group or gender
or parental status or household income
saw or ad but not only SAR ad that would
be Impressions but clicked on our bad
and how much they spent per click and
how many conversions so you have all
that data available to you in the
Display Network okay so that's
demographics I can also use topics so I
can take I can choose a particular topic
to advertise on so if I choose topics I
can choose a particular keyword find a
particular topic or I can drill down on
Google's topic categories and
subcategories so here you can see online
communities if I choose that one I could
see there are other subcategories under
online communities okay I can choose the
whole category of science or I can drill
down to see what subcategories are under
science so I can do that for any one of
these topic categories and if I choose a
category notice that's where Google is
going to place my ad whatever I select
again notice upper right here I can take
a sneak peek at how many eyeball Google
is expecting to see my ad so here by
choosing astronomy and science I have
310 million impressions that's how many
potential eyeballs can look at my ad so
if you're setting up a Display Network
campaign you can choose keywords you can
choose demographics or you could choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
a topic then your last option here is
placements so I can pick and choose a
specific placement if there's a
particular website that I want to
advertise on let's just say
newyorktimes.com or or latimes.com or
webmd.com remember there are over two
main websites on Google's Display
Network so I can pick and choose
specifically where I want my ads to be
displayed now when you're done choosing
your audience or your keywords or your
demographics your topics or specific
placements you can always then go to
your placements and then click on where
ADS showed and so now over this
particular time frame I'm going to be
able to see where my ads have been shown
and so now I can see my ads have been
shown my mobile apps and on particular
websites now if you don't like any of
the particular websites that your ad is
showing on you can always select it and
you can always exclude it can exclude it
from the ad group or the campaign okay
so that's how you manage where your ads
are showing up on Google's Display
Network again you can go ahead and go to
where ADS are shown under placements and
over that particular period of time
Google's going to show you where your
ads been shown and if you don't like
that placement then you can always just
exclude it or if you don't like the
performance meaning you're not getting
many Impressions or you're not getting
any clicks or the click-through rates
very low you can go ahead and exclude it
so this is an opportunity for you the
advertiser to take control over where
your ads are shown so in summary when
you set up a display campaign on
Google's Display Network you have
options if you're remarketing you're
going to choose your audience you're
going to choose your audience using a
list you created in Google analytics if
you're on the display network not
remarketing you have the option you can
choose a keyword and have Google place
your ad on a website that fits the
description of that keyword you could
choose specific demographics you could
choose a topic or subtopic category or
you can choose a specific placement okay
those are all the options available to
you when you run your ad on Google's
Display Network now let's go back and
take a look at some of the advantages of
the Google Display Network so I just
went over with you how to actually
create a campaign in an ad group I
actually went over how to set up upper
marketing campaign and set up a
marketing list and analytics and I went
over all the differences between the
search Network and display but let's
really hone in on those advantages here
so with the Display Network we can
provide Advanced targeting meaning I can
particularly point to a specific website
that I want to advertise on so that's
what I mean by Advanced targeting or if
I don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds I can
exclude them or I can really pick and
choose a specific audience that I want
to remarket to so those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done with an analytics or Google ads so
Advanced targeting enables you to target
the people that didn't engage with
previous campaigns and get in front of
people with look-alike audiences that
can be created based on the audience you
usually advertise to so in other words
we can really hone own in and pick and
choose who we want to advertise to
another Advantage is relatively low
starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost is normally on the search
Network you're bidding on keywords and
some keywords can be very competitive
whereas on the Display Network you could
pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose where
you want to advertise so you can really
advertise on websites to get a lot of
traffic may not have a lot of
competition and therefore may not cost
as much so if you compare to traditional
forms of advertising like TV or radio
display advertising reaching a large
broader audience is a lot cheaper you
can do Advanced tracking meaning when we
talk about perform Advanced tracking
we're talking about again remarketing we
can really pick and choose who we want
to remarket to and cookie them and pick
and choose how long they are going to be
cooking so we talk about Advanced
tracking that's what we're really
talking about so we can also talk about
how how many times our ad is shown to
somebody we really can pick and choose
how many times we want somebody to
actually see our ad on a site based on
performance okay let's take a look at
some other advantages the ability to
advertise your brand to a broader
audience can Google has over 2 million
websites so we can pick and choose where
really where we want our ads to show up
again it could be by topic it could be
contextually via keywords or it can be
specific websites so we can create
demand for our products and what we mean
by that we can create really cool ads
remember rich media ads video ads these
are all engaging type of ads those are
ad Types on the Display Network we
create engaging type of ads it's going
to appeal to somebody and they're going
to engage so we have that opportunity
just based on the different ad types of
course increasing web traffic we can't
say that enough if you're advertising on
Google Display Network you have the
opportunity get your ad in front of
millions of people get in front our ads
in front of millions of people we have
the opportunity to get a lot of clicks
and we do have that wide range of
formats search Network only has text ads
here we have text we have rich media we
have image we have video so all these
types of AD formats allow us to really
get our ads out there in a number of
different ways again remarketing our
product the sources of the big big big
advantage using Google's Display Network
that's how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such a key feature so if
somebody comes to our website and
doesn't do it we want them to do we can
cookie them and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailor to that
audience today we're going to talk about
Google analytics we're going to start
out with how to set up a Google
analytics account and so we're going to
talk about everything that entails
including creating your Google Analytics
account we're going to talk about
setting up a property in your account
and what a property is we're going to
talk about setting up a reporting view
in your property and we're going to talk
about installing the tracking code so
those are the series of steps we're
going to go through today in terms of
setting up a Google analytics account so
let's get right to it and so really the
Bruin prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're going to go walk through a series
of steps but really that's really all
you need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be to name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different industry
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in okay and then you have some
additional options here okay so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs and education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what
Google's going to do is share your data
that it collects on your website in this
case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously with others in the
industry in this case jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share Anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see what
other websites or how other websites are
performing compared to ours what's the
Benchmark in our industry and so the
benchmarking to me is important and I'm
gonna go over that in a few minutes when
we go over the different reports but to
me I would always opt into benchmarking
because this is the only report Google
provides in analytics about how others
in your industry is performing versus
your website okay so it's a way to
compare your website performance against
others in the same industry the other
options here technical support and
account specialist I would also
recommend you opt into those because
then it allows you to basically Google
allow Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
associated with your account and so this
number is going to be associated with
your account so your account ID starts
with UA and it's going to be this number
here now the dash one is the property
you set up so in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple property just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
on every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in the
ID now there's an alternative to adding
the Google analytics tracking code to
your site and that's Google tag manager
so Google tag manager is the way I would
recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager the that's the route I would go
now once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a plug-in
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google is going to
do is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look some
something like this if I click on demo
account here it's going to add to my
Google analytics account so I'm going to
have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar you're not sure what
you're getting yourself into so think of
the demo account as kind of a test drive
you're test driving Google analytics
before you even add any code to your
website so again all you need is a
Google account and if you have a Google
account and you add the demo account to
your Google analytics account you're
going to be able to see how analytics
works okay and so that's what I would
also recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around Google analytics to see the
different types of reports it has to
offer now when you do actually set up a
Google analytics account you're going to
have some settings that you're going to
want to pay attention to so when you set
up the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here in
this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports parts that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm in admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page page two active
users on the Google's women's white t
page so forth and so on now most
importantly if you have a vent tracking
set up so if you're taking a look at our
Google tag manager webinar you know that
you could set up event tracking in
Google analytics to measure engagement
on your website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current current events
that I have currently firing on the
website and that's what's currently fire
now if I want to look at the events that
have happened in the last 30 minutes I
could just click on this link here last
30 minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm going to see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we could still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interest do they have what
browser did they use so we can paint a
nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented
English-speaking users from Great
Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken and down into two categories
they're either returning or they're new
so when you add the Google analytics
tracking script to your website what's
going to happen is if a user or when a
user goes to your website they're going
to get cookied if it's the first time
they've been to your website what Google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking at analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about twenty three
twenty four percent are returning users
okay so I can get a good breakdown of
what type of users are coming am I
driving new traffic am I driving traffic
that's been to my website before what
language are they speaking okay I can
also paint a bigger picture how old are
they are they what gender are they do
they come from mobile so let's take a
look at some of these different reports
under audience so if I skip down now to
demographics I can click on overview and
when that report loads I can see now
under demographics overview I can see
the breakout of age ranges and so here I
can see the majority of the traffic
coming to my site again over the past
week now if I want to change this date
range I could simply do that I can
change the date range just by clicking
in on the date range and then maybe
going say the last 30 days and I can
even compare it to the previous period
or the previous year I'm going to choose
the last 30 days I'm going to click
apply now I'm looking at data over the
last 30 days and again you can change
the date range to any range you want you
can only go back as far as when you
actually created the Google analytics
account you can't go prior to that so
here I'm looking at the last 30 days and
I can see almost 47 percent of my users
were in their age range of 25 to 34. now
when it comes to gender I can say 66
percent represent males so I can get a
breakout of gender and age as well as
interest and click on interest and look
at the overview there and see what the
interest is of the users who are coming
to my site based on in-market segments
or Affinity I can also choose language
and location so if I want to know
exactly where my users are located when
they're coming to my website I can click
on location and here I can get a
breakout 43 of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here I can see if I have an
e-commerce website I can see of those 43
percent 0.29 percent of those converted
or purchased something and that equates
to 94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 of the
traffic so desktop still represents a
majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce rate is approximately 48 percent
and bounce rate means that if a user in
this case for mobile landed on a page
they left the site without going any
further so they consider it a bounce if
they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have have an e-commerce website
you want people who come to your website
to purchase and so here we can see 48
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on average do mobile users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.86 on desktop it's
4.5 now if I look a little bit further
in engagement I want to be able to
measure how long somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48 percent but they're also looking
at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four pages per
session then that means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough I can see that
mobile over the last 30 days had more
transactions so 51 transactions verses
34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is this
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click okay and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if I close that up you can see
audience real time customization if I
click on customization if I click on
Save reports I should be able to see my
save report here and I do so here I can
see mobile report if I click on it I can
simply go to the report I was looking at
before I saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature in analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we're setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and I recommended
you do so and so if you did I actually
opt into benchmarking then you're going
to be able to see see how your site
compares to others in the same industry
so if I click on benchmarking and then
click on channels what I'm actually able
to do now is compare my website with
others in the same industry so if I go
back to say jobs and education and I
choose education all education as my
industry vertical I should be able to
see websites that are in the same
particular industry and how I compare
with those websites so I'm choosing all
countries I can narrow that down if I
wanted to I can just search for the
United States I can choose a specific
State and then I can choose a particular
site size so here I'm choosing sites by
daily session so these are sites that
have an average of 5 000 to almost 10
000 sessions a day and so in this
vertical education in the United States
sites that have 5 000 to 9
999 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria I chose now if my site
is similar meaning if I'm in the United
States if I'm in education and I'm
receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions per
day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 worse in terms of the
amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison whereas something in
green is a positive comparison so if I
look at engagement I can see that I
might not be driving as much traffic but
I can see that the pages per session are
better than the side average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again looking just at organic search I
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry and your kind country
region and based on the size of your
website in terms of how many visitors or
sessions you're getting per day so let's
go from audience to acquisition so if
audience is who is coming to your
website acquisition allows us to see how
the traffic was driven to your website
so how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our
websites they come via organic search
meaning do they type something into
Google and find you in the organic
listing analytics also groups users
based on whether they came to your site
directly meaning did they type in the
URL directly into the browser or did
they bookmark your website and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I could
see how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that at those four fifty four thousand
users I had seventy thousand sessions I
could see my average bounce rate was 43
the pages per session we're just just
over 4 and the average session duration
how long did somebody stay on my website
on average about two minutes and 55
seconds the average conversion rate was
0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500 okay and
that's all over the last 30 days so any
report you look at in analytics is going
to have a summary and note that any
to allow you to save it so if it's a
report you think you're going to go back
and look at at a future date then you
simply just have to click on the save
button conversely if you don't want to
save it you can simply just export it so
you can export it as a PDF if I click on
PDF it's going to allow me to export
that as a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
could connect Google ads to analytics
and this is key because now I can see
how many people are coming from Google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much a pain per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent 810 dollars over the last 30 days
and received 858 dollars in Revenue so
you want to make sure that you link up
your Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for this very reason
you want to be able to see how your
Google ads campaigns perform once the
users get to your website and so I want
to see if they're engaging and I want to
see if they're converting so they're all
sorts of reports under Google ads so you
can look at it by keywords by search
queries by hour of the day if you're
running display campaigns you can look
at display targeting says all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
face Facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they got
to your website once they landed on a
page on your website how did they behave
so when we looked at audience we got a
sense of who is coming with acquisition
we get a sense of how the traffic got to
our website did they come from organic
do direct social Etc the behavior
reports allow us to actually measure how
that traffic behave once they landed on
a page on our website and so if I go to
overview under Behavior now I'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many pages I've had and a page view is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many pages I've
had again over the last 30 days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics okay the average
bounce rate the average time on page I
can look at the exit rate which means
how many people actually exited or the
percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
you unique page view but in this case
the home page if they look at the home
page a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my landing page report I can
see the home page had 36
000 17 sessions in the last 30 days
that's how many people landed on the
home page so here I can see 71 percent
were news sessions meaning that I had a
lot of new users who landed on the home
page in fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page for new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute you to a goal or conversion
and in this case I can see of those 36
000 sessions I had 22 transactions
totaling 1200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of 0.06
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to 0.06 percent of
the revenue so this gives you an idea of
when somebody lands on your website and
they land on a page is that page helping
to move that person along meaning are
they not bouncing and is that page
helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because because what Google
analytics does is they take a sampling
of pages and in this case you can see
over the last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from mine
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser with the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the low time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do is
it's going to show me the page load Time
by Page and then it's actually going to
provide a link where I can actually
click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google repo
report called page speed insights and
Page speed insights is going to give me
some information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how how people are
converting or if they're not converting
on our website and so in Google
analytics we have the opportunity to set
up goals now you have the opportunity to
set up 20 goals in your Google analytics
View and so to set up a goal okay so
you're going to click on admin and Under
The View you're going to see goals and
so if you don't even have goals the
first step is to create goals and so you
have four different goal types in
analytics so you have pages per session
so how many pages per session is so if
your goal is set to say three or two if
somebody actually looked at two or three
pages per session it's going to count as
a goal okay so if I look here I can see
I have pages per session set at 10. so
that means that if a user came to the
site looked at more than 10 pages per
session then it's going to count as a
goal another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case I can see here that the goal
is set to this particular page here and
so when somebody actually lands on that
page it's going to count as a goal now
there are two other goal ties we can
look at one is duration so just like
pages per session in our previous
example is somebody looked at 10 pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal with duration it's based on time so
in this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds then that
means if a user comes to my website and
they spend at least one minute and 30
seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in Google analytics is an event
based goal so when you set up event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal so if somebody clicks on say the
submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's going to count as a goal so
you have four different goal types in
Google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if I look at goals overview I can
be able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal 2 engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 percent
meaning that I had 7 000 of all the
users that came to the website seven
thousand gold completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and then the great thing
about Google analytics here is that I
can actually see by segments so the
default segment in a segment is just
looking at a specific user set so the
default segment is always all users
however I can choose a different segment
so if I want to choose instead of all
users if I want to choose Mobile Traffic
I can select Mobile Traffic hit apply so
I'm actually now looking at a subset of
data I'm looking at mobile traffic so if
all the mobile users have come to my
site I can see 1400 engaged or looked at
10 pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination nation is my top
conversion combination of the last 30
days my second best conversion grouping
is organic search and direct meaning
that a user came to the website via
organic search first did not convert and
then came back via direct the second
time and converted so basically what
analytics does is give credit to the
last referral meaning if you came to the
website via referral or referring
website and converted then the referring
website's gonna get the credit for the
conversion but analytics does a good job
of showing you how different channels
work together so a channel may drive a
lot of traffic like organic search but
that traffic may not convert the first
time around for number of different
reasons whether it could be brand
recognition Price shopping reading
content whatever the case analytics is
able to measure if that channel actually
did contribute at a later point and in
this case we could see organic search
drove traffic that didn't convert but
that traffic came back a second time via
direct and did convert so that's our
second best Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to to improve your website
performance how to set up goals in
Google analytics so for this particular
webinar we're going to jump into Google
analytics directly and spend all of our
time there because it's about learning
practical applications so goals are
important goals let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
click on admin here and admin will take
you to basically a screen that looks
like this where you have an account
column you have your property column and
then you have your view column now the
view column is where you're going to go
to set up goals okay so every view in
every property has up to 20 goals okay
so by default in analytics you're going
to have at least one view for your
property so if I have a property I'm
gonna have at least one view but if I
happen to set up multiple views like you
see here then I know for every view I
set up I have 20 goals to work with so
where are those goals so Under The View
I'm going to click on goals and now I
could see I have 20 at my disposal now
you can see here by clicking on the
recording column I can see I have in
this particular property this particular
view I have five gold that are active so
you can use up to 20 but you don't have
to have 20 active Okay you can have one
active two active my recommendation is
least have one goal again when you set
up a goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't no longer want to use a goal I
could simply just turn it off if I want
to continue using it just turn it on
okay it's that simple you could turn on
and off goals so here I already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in Google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay or are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying trying
to measure now when you actually do go
to set up a goal you're going to click
on the red CTA button that says new goal
so analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal id5 I'm going to be able to
see those goals and goal set one and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active and goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set three Etc notice I don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that are
in goal set four therefore I don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose custom as
our goal setup we're going to type type
in a gold name I'm just going to say
thank you okay this is goal 15. now this
is the important part Google analytics
has four different goal types
destination duration pages per session
or screens per session to screens per
session is related to mobile because
Google analytics measures mobile app
activity and then you have an event so
we're going to cover all four of these
but for the sake of this simple example
I'm going to choose destination why
because if somebody goes to that thank
you page we're going to go ahead and put
in the thank you page as the goal the
goal URL so for example destination is
my choice I'm going to click continue
now this is where I'm gonna put the URL
so if my URL is just simply thank
you.html I can just go ahead and put
thank you.html or if it's just thank you
then I can just do thank you depends on
on the website depends on the URI
structure so whatever that URL is that's
what you're going to put in and when
you're done you can verify it so what
Google analytics does is actually we'll
verify over the last seven days if
anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct URL then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the URL here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so Google
analytics actually has options so we're
saying thank you is equal to so the
destination URL is equal to thank you or
thank you.html or thank you dot ESP or
whatever that thank you page is okay
okay you do have options so if you have
a long URL you could say begins with and
you could say it begins with say thank
you so this is the logic we're going to
say hey if anybody goes to a URL that
begins with thank you then count it as a
goal or you could say equals two so if
anybody goes to a URL that equals two
thank you then count it as a goal you
have one more option Here regular
expression so Google analytics
understands the language of regular
Expressions so regular Express
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with Google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with or ends
with so we can you know use characters
like the dollar sign ends with or begins
with so we can always do that so you can
use regular Expressions as well if
you're familiar with regular Expressions
if you're not then you don't have to use
them but there are special characters
where that you can insert in that are
used as regular expression so if you're
not familiar with regular expression
don't choose that option you could
choose the other option of equals to or
begins with now note that on all three
of these options I didn't put the domain
so if my domain is Amma Dash
foundation.org and then thank you I
don't need to put the domain because
analytics is already knows what domain
we're tracking so you don't have to put
in the domain here when you're entering
in in this case the Google URL so you
can omit the domain so when you put in
that URL you know that you have three
options to work with and then you always
always want to verify that goal URL you
always want to verify it because if you
see zero percent conversion and in this
case of the last seven days then that
should tell you something either your
goal is not set up correctly or you just
don't have any conversions either way
you want to double check that now when
it comes to the destination URL goal you
do have an option here for funnel so if
I turn on funnel then that means I have
the ability to track how people went
through my funnel so if I have a cart
and I want to be able to check how many
people go in and out of the cart then I
have the option of adding specific Pages
as part of the cart so we could say you
know step one which is basically cart we
could say step two is billing
information that could be slash billing
we could see step three is shipping
information slash shipping and then step
four could be you know confirm and that
could be slash confirmation so whatever
your url structure is for your cart and
it doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnel is available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step required so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
all and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the storefront page so
over this particular period of time I
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront Page 6 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and five
exited the site altogether okay so that
gave me 87 total and from 87 I saw that
82 went on to the next page for the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the cart page out of
84 that's 75 percent so from the cart
page to the create your account page we
had 94 move on so we didn't have anybody
enter in the create your account page we
didn't have anybody leave to create your
account page so if 82 82 create your
account and then we have 82 move on to
the payment page so that's a hundred
percent okay we have one exit so we have
81 that proceeded to be beyond the
payment page which was purchased so 81
of 82 is 98
and we started with 84. so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 funnel
conversion rate so 75 percent of the
people who entered in the funnel went on
to purchase okay so don't be confused
with the overall e-commerce conversion
rate so 75 is the funnel conversion rate
the overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is
18.45 over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18 of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
final 75 converted so that's a look at
the funnel so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off how
effective our funnel is what pages we
need to address in that funnel okay so
that's the whole point of the funnel and
the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
if we verify this goal we could see over
the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure is
for example if we set the goal to three
pages per session then we're going to be
able to measure if how many people went
to the site and looked at three pages
per session so let's take a look at that
goal so if I open up the goal here I can
see three pages per session is what
we're naming it so basically what we're
asking analytics to do is anything
greater than two pages which would be 3
and Beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verified over the
last seven days we could see a 4.12
conversion rate and that tells me that
four percent of my traffic over the last
seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to day you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now
now I have 1.21 pages per session so
that's on average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a ten percent so I could see
that or people coming from organic
search are staying on the site longer or
they're looking at more pages than any
other channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to sign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you can test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name so has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category and action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you could say I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
can see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I could see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assistive
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together
to contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
how to set up event tracking in Google
analytics so welcome and let's get
started so many of you out there have a
website similar to the one I'm looking
at now this is a non-profit that I work
with I'm a foundation and like this
website and probably like your website
you probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wanding around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
events you're going to need to set up
event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we got to donate now Bob
we got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they know looked at how long they
stayed on that page what page they left
from more or less they're timing how
long somebody stays on the website and
what pages they look at so there's more
to a website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the Donate Now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step step one identify what you
want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category
header donate now I need to give an
action to each category and so in this
case I'm just going to say click because
that's what the action is doing it's
it's somebody's taking the action of
clicking now if it's a video and it's a
play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if we
go back in analytics here I could see
some categories and if I click on action
I can see some actions that I've named
now step three so we've identified in
Step One what we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into Google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
Google search for Google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up event
tracking now tag managers use for a lot
of different things but the main thing
we're doing here is setting up an event
for our website and so I'm logged in to
the same email address I'm using for
analytics okay so now I'm in tag manager
and I want to set up my event for this
donate Now button so what do I need to
do well for every event I want to set up
I need to set up a tag okay so if I go
to tags I can see I already have some
tags set up and some of these are events
and so when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it GA Dash event
Dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the Donate Now button on
our website so we're in Google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if I click
on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page view we're tracking an
event and so now remember in step two
you identified what you want to call
that category you identify what you want
to call that action and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donates the name of
our category and our action is click and
if you want to add in a label and a
value so if you want to sign a value you
can if you want to add in a label you
can okay those are optional so you just
need to focus on category in action and
then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to out a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be a
non-interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so I don't want it to be a bounce
I want it to be an interaction so my
advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose Google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
Google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to false so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
as an interaction and therefore not
count as a bounce if somebody landed on
that page so that's more or less all you
need to do to set up the tag in the
Google tag manager now if somebody else
is setting up the tag for you then again
you want to revert to step two you want
to be able to give that person the
appropriate category action and or label
and or value why because you're the one
that's going to be going into Google
analytics and you're the one that's
going to have to go to behavior events
top events and look for the particular
at category in action and or label so
you need to be able to communicate that
information to whomever is setting up
the tag now if it's you great you
already know what it is because you're
entering that information into tag
manager so in this case I'm going to go
ahead and choose a variable for my label
parameter and and why do I want to do
that because in tag manager I have
something at my disposal called
variables and variables allow you to see
specifically things that are being
tracked so in this case I chose pagepath
okay so pagepath is a URL and why did I
choose page path as my variable for the
parameter label because if somebody does
click on the header donate button and
the header donate button on our website
is on every page so if I go to the
children's page I'm still going to see
that header donate button and so for me
I want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that header donate
button and so this allows me to actually
see in Google analytics what page
somebody clicked on the header donate
Now button and so now if I go back to
GTM Google tag manager I have a category
I have an action and I have a label
which is a variable okay so note that in
Google tag manager you have a lot of
different variables at your disposal and
variables are there to help you identify
specifically what is being tracked so
take a look at all the variables at your
disposal and tag manager in this example
I'm using page path so now once you set
up your tag pretty straightforward again
tag types Google analytics track type is
event you are assigning the category
action and or label and or value you're
changing or leaving the default in place
for non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this particular event and so if I
click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links I'm actually
saying Hey Google tag manager fire this
event when the click ID equals header
donate button now it just so happens
that if somebody did click on this
donate Now button they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when I
actually inspect the element I can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper Pane and in the
lower pane I can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if I hone in a
little it I could see ID equals header
Dash donate dash button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to file higher that event so if somebody
clicks on a button that equals header
Dash donate dash button it's going to
fire that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our events we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on omagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under Behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am I going to look for in this case
I'm going to look for header donate okay
if I click on hit or donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that header donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay and preview
mode allows you to see in analytics and
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I could see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to refresh and
in my browser same browser I'm using for
tag manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already okay
because I'm in preview mode so here I
could see remarketing I could see page
views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode there's my event
header donate and I can see it fired so
now I can see it fired in the preview
mode so in addition to Google analytics
in preview mode I could see that that
tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time and
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it GA Dash events that way
you can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website that's the best practice
what I would recommend is set up a
spreadsheet and in that spreadsheet you
know you want to put a note what's
firing what are you doing to fire it
could be in this case someone somebody
clicks on the Donate Now button in the
header you want to put the tag name in
here the type okay then you want to
record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go in analytics
and I go to admin and I go to go tools
if you set up a new goal okay all you
need to do is choose custom click
continue you're going to choose event as
your goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if I click now continue what is my
category it's equal to header donate my
action is click and so I can verify to
see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and I
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal in
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what I would
recommend if the event is equal to a kpi
or business goal or it's of importance
it's something you really want to
measure okay if it's just a click say on
a Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you've recorded
it in your spreadsheet it's firing you
want to be able to then go back into
Behavior back into events okay you can
go to top events okay so top events tell
you by category as a default what events
are firing or what category is firing
the most okay so if I choose my date
range here I can just go to here to date
so here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have have
per event so it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value divided by the total number of
unique Pages or sessions and so because
I don't have value I'm not going to have
average value but here you can see
because value is optional here I can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique and the total
events and if I click on label if I have
a label assigned then I'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're going to go
to analyze the data
building a presence on YouTube is like
fine-tuning the engine of a car to get
maximum performance in YouTube terms
this means maximum views and maximum
subscribers to your YouTube channel
the instruments you have for this are
the video itself how you optimize it in
YouTube and the quality of the YouTube
channel you create to promote your
YouTube presence
if you do get maximum performance out of
your YouTube presence YouTube will
reward you by giving you the opportunity
to monetize your YouTube videos through
the YouTube advertising platforms
by the end of this lesson you will know
how to use the new YouTube Studio beta
how to upload and optimize a YouTube
video
how to create and optimize a YouTube
channel
how to create a playlist on your YouTube
how to make a great video and how to
monetize your YouTube presence
YouTube has just launched the new
YouTube Studio beta most of the YouTube
features like uploading and optimizing
your videos have been brought into the
new YouTube Studio better some of the
features like creating your YouTube
channel still need to be accessed
through the old version of YouTube
Studio soon these features will be
brought into the new version which will
make the old version obsolete
when you are successful in YouTube in
views and subscribers YouTube will give
you the opportunity to monetize your
YouTube presence
upload video on desktop
to upload a video on YouTube you can do
that on the desktop and you can also do
that on the mobile
let's have a look at the desktop version
of uploading your video
so what you do is you go to the
youtube.com home page and as long as
you're logged into your Google account
you see your little login account info
here
you will then see on the left a little
camera with a plus sign and that's where
you can upload a video click on that you
can then upload your video or you can go
live streaming so let's click on upload
video and that takes you to this screen
where you can select a file to upload or
you can drag and drop the video file you
can immediately add the settings for
published public unlisted private or you
can schedule the video you can also
import videos from your Google photos
drive you can start live streaming from
here as well and there is a new feature
which is called Premiere this is where
you can schedule a video and invite your
followers to watch the video together
with you and when the schedule dates is
there the video goes public on YouTube
and you can watch it together on the
premiere screen
so what I'm going to do is to select the
file to upload I just click on the
finder and then I can drag the video
file here in the Box
and while it is uploading I can enter
basic info of the video in this case I
will call it flower garden in Malaysia
you can then give a description you can
set tags
so when the processing of the video is
complete you can pick your thumbnail and
then you click publish and you will see
that the video is Live on YouTube
so let's select set the thumbnail you
can see that the processing is done and
here I click to publish the video is now
live so if I click here on the link it
will actually take me to the video and
there is my video on YouTube The Flower
garden in Malaysia
upload video on mobile
to upload a video through your mobile
you have to use the YouTube mobile app
once you start a mobile app you will see
at the top of the little video icon
when I click on that icon there are
various options you can choose from I
can click record if I want to create a
video that I want to upload I can click
on go live that takes me straight into
the live streaming of my video or I can
select a video from the video library on
my phone so for this demo I will click
on select the video and then I can
select a video that I want to upload
there are some basic editing functions I
have on the video I'll show that in a
later demo and if I want to select this
video I click on next and as we saw with
the desktop demo I can add a name and
the description of the video and I can
then upload a video on YouTube
the video is now uploaded so once the
video is ready you will see it in the
list of the videos and then obviously
you can go into the edit mode to add
more details in the title or in the
description and optimize your video
so now you see that the video is
uploaded to my list of videos on YouTube
and you can also see it's just placed
above the video that I just uploaded
through the desktop version of YouTube
YouTube Studio bedtime
YouTube has come up with a new version
of the interface to manage your videos
on YouTube it's called YouTube Studio
beta not all the features have moved to
the new version for those features that
haven't migrated yet YouTube will but
direct you to the old version of the
interface or if you prefer the old
interface YouTube will still give you
the option to switch back to it
but like they do with migrations to new
interfaces after a few months they will
switch the option to move back off
the new interface is very simple to use
let me show you the desktop version of
it and then I will show you the mobile
app for it
to access YouTube Creator Studio beta
you have to be logged into your Google
account and when you're on the
youtube.com home page you click on your
little photo here on the right and then
you click on YouTube Studio better
that will take you to the YouTube Studio
beta dashboard
what you see here at the bottom left is
Creator Studio Classic so you can still
switch back to the classic format of the
Creator studio and again if you want to
switch back to the studio better you
click here on create a studio beta to go
back to the new interface
there are still a few features like
creating playlists translations
transcriptions that sit in the old
version
when you select those you will go back
to Creator Studio Classic
so what's there to see on the dashboard
first of all you have your latest video
that you uploaded with some basic
information
you can go to the video analytics of
this particular video and the see
comments
you also get a list of your channel
analytics highlights
it gives you a link to your channel
analytics and your top videos of the
last two hours
and then here you see content that
YouTube presents like YouTube news and
information about Creator Insider
here they give you additional videos
where you can learn about how to use
YouTube
it will also show you some ideas on how
to improve your Channel or in this case
help navigating the new interface
here on the left you have your main menu
you can go into your videos analytics
check out the comments go to the
transcriptions of your videos and other
features
and then down here you have your
settings and Link back to the Creator
Studio Classic
so if we click here on videos you have a
list of all the videos that you have
uploaded on YouTube
it's much friendlier and much better
accessible than in the old Creator
Studio Classic so here you see the two
videos that we've just uploaded
and then here you see what is the
visibility of the video and the date
that you published it
you'll also see how many views how many
comments and how many likes or dislikes
a really good new feature here is the
inline editing as we call this if I want
to quickly change the title or the
description of this video I don't have
to open the video and click on edit I
can actually click it here I can
actually change it here in line so
there's a few things I can do in line
edit the title and the description get a
link promote for advertising download or
delete the video
so if I say edit title and description
and add in Cotswolds and then in here
I'm just clicking and then I'm just
clicking save and you see it will
automatically change the title so this
is a very easy and convenient new
feature I can click here and see the
video directly on YouTube as well
and here you see the analytics so when
you click on analytics it takes you to
the general overview of the analytics
where you can see what's the activity
and what's the views that we got in our
Channel
what are the top videos that people are
watching what is the real-time activity
happening on your videos and then you
can see here about the viewers the
interest of the viewers the built-in
audience and how to earn Revenue
so we'll get back into the analytics
later but at least here you have an idea
of what you can get from the Analytics
you can then check out the comments that
you had on the various videos
you can look at the transcription files
that you've had for your videos and
which ones have been published and then
it takes you to your other features as
well
in the settings you can set things like
the currency that you're using what your
default experience is for the classic or
for the new YouTube Studio better
you can have your channel settings like
the name of your channel the keywords
for your channel and the country for
your Channel
you can check on your community you can
add filters you can look at the
moderators and to proved users that you
can add and you can look at other
settings like your Advanced channel
settings or Channel branding
but you will access these through the
Creator Studio Classic
so this gives you a short overview of
the Creator Studio beta
using YouTube Studio on a mobile
to access YouTube Studio on your mobile
you have to download a mobile app and
then when you open the mobile app you
could almost like a similar experiences
on the desktop
it starts with your dashboard
this gives you an overview of your
analytics of the last 28 days the last
videos that you uploaded the last
comments that you received and the total
number of subscribers you have to your
Channel
to access the menu you tap on the
hamburger button on the top left and
this gives you a similar list of options
that you have on the desktop version you
can go to your videos you can check your
playlist check the comments go to your
analytics and change your YouTube
settings
when I click on videos it gives you a
list of all the videos that you uploaded
for each video you see the number of
views the number of comments the number
of likes the number of dislikes you can
sort the videos by most recent most
viewed and you can look at all the
videos you can filter by draft by public
unlisted and private videos
the few from your mobile is very easy
and it's simple to browse through all
the videos that you've uploaded on your
mobile you can look at your playlist and
make some changes to your playlist
and then you can also check the comments
on the videos
if you click on analytics you get more
detailed stats about your videos you can
see your overview any Revenue that you
would have made you can look at
analytics for your playlist and it also
gives you analytics of any interactive
content that you have used in your
videos like click-throughs or cards
let's go back to the dashboard to
complete this demo this gives you an
idea of what you can manage through the
YouTube studio app
now that your video is uploaded on
YouTube there are two things that you
may want to do first you may want to
edit the video like trimming the
beginning or the end or adding some
special effects to the video and you
definitely have to optimize the video
for search on both YouTube and Google
so let's have a look at both of these
areas and to start with editing the
video
let's take for instance this video here
a video blog that I did a little while
ago
if I click on the video it takes me to
the area where I can add the information
to optimize the video and I'll come back
to that later
but here you can click on editor and
this takes me to a full screen video
editing mode it's a very basic video
editing so it doesn't give you all the
functionality like for instance iMovie
or Adobe Premiere but it does the thing
for you if you want to make some quick
changes to the video you can trim the
video you can add music or play with the
sound of the video you can add an end
screen to the video and you could blur
faces for instance on the video These
are basic functions but they work really
well let's have a look first at the
sound
if I click here on audio and I open the
audio library that YouTube has it gives
you a full library of royalty-free music
tracks that you can add to your video so
for instance I can select hear the noise
I can add that to my video when it's too
loud you have a slider where you can say
favorite to the original audio so now
you hear my voice in the background in
today's video blog let's go back now and
close this
you can also add an end screen to the
video and there are a number of
templates you can choose from
an end screen will show during the last
20 seconds of the video you can show a
playlist or a subscribe button or you
can have reference to two different
videos or two videos or playlists so
different formats that you can choose
from let's pick the two video template
when I click on apply then here you
would see how that will show in the last
20 seconds of the video when I play the
video you see that I haven't added any
video but this is how it would show as
an end screen in your video
and then you can add blur to a video as
well you can blur faces or you can blur
specific areas in your video
this is all I will be showing you on
editing your video as I said before it's
a basic video editor but if you want to
do some quick editing on your video
before you publish it then this is a
really good tool to do just that
so the next thing you want to do is to
optimize your video for YouTube search
and for Google search so how do you go
about it when you select a video let's
take this one Epic Fail how to ruin your
life on an EasyJet flight
you click on the video and that takes
you to the basic optimization screen
there are a few things that are
important here first of all the title
this title epic fail how to ruin your
life on an EasyJet flight is an
interesting title it tells people
there's something happening here it's
very important to use your words like
epic fail people like seeing videos with
epic fails so remember title is
extremely important
there are two reasons why people decide
to watch a video on YouTube number one
is the title number two is the thumbnail
and that's the next thing you want to
optimize YouTube will pick a few
thumbnails based on your video but you
can also upload your own thumbnail the
third part is also important the
description of your video it's important
that the description of the video is in
line with the title and what the viewer
is going to see
make sure you use keywords that are
relevant to the video and to your
business
and here you can add tags tags are key
for the search it helps people to find
your video based on the tags that you've
set
here you can see the public URL of your
video and here you can decide on the
visibility of your video do you want
your video to be public private or
unlisted unlisted video will be public
but they won't show up in the search
here you can select a playlist that you
want the video to be part of you can
assign a video to the various playlists
that you have on your Channel
this is where you can create cards in
the end screen in the video editing demo
we looked at how you can add end screens
and how you can add video cards to your
video
if you click on it then you see the
editing mode and here are the different
types of cards that you can add
like a video or a playlist or a Channel
or you could even create a poll where
you encourage viewers to participate
so you just click on the create and then
you can pick a video from the list that
shows up
that video will actually show up and
then here you see where the video card
will appear
so if we go to the beginning of the
video and we would click play Then here
you see the suggested video popping up
so you can now save the changes and go
back to the editor
so these are the basic settings for the
optimization of your video and you can
also go to the advanced settings there's
a lot more that you can add in the
advanced settings
you can add the recording date the
location of the video and you can also
add the license and write ownership of
the video
if you are part of the commercial
network with YouTube you can select a
syndication where you want your videos
to show
you can select a category for your video
the language and the caption
certification when there may be
television FCC regulations regarding
closed captions
also upload your subtitles and closed
captioning YouTube will actually create
subtitles for you and then you can check
that later
it is not 100 accurate but at least it's
a good starting point for your subtitles
finally you can set things like allowing
comments and ratings and enabling age
restrictions as well
you can allow people to embed the video
and you can also tick whether the video
contains paid promotion like product
placement sponsorships or endorsements
so lots of things that you can set in
the optimization and when you're happy
with it you just click save
Google and YouTube will then include all
these settings in the indexing of the
video and the better you do all this the
more likely your video will show up in
the search
so let's go to Google and check this
Epic Fail video
we have a good thumbnail and a good
title
if you go to Google and search for epic
fail EasyJet for instance then you see
that the video immediately shows up here
in Google and that's obviously what you
want for your videos you want them to
show up high in the videos or in the
image section of the search results page
and if you do the same search in YouTube
then you would like your video to show
up as well and you see here immediately
it shows up as the first video
so this is all there is to optimizing
your video
another important part and we briefly
touched on this are the subtitles and
the transcriptions that you may want to
add to your video
first you want to check if YouTube
created transcriptions for your video
take this video blog for example if I
select other Futures you see here
translation and transcription
the automated transcription from YouTube
has not been brought into the new studio
beta so I need to go to the old Studio
of YouTube
so I click here on the old classic
Creator Studio translation and
transcription and then here you see the
link to the published transcript file I
haven't put it in this is something that
YouTube will do when it's a video that's
worth transcribing
you could copy the texture you can
download it and then use that for a blog
post or for the show notes of your
podcast you can also add language and
you can set the transcription on
published or draft
very useful features and very important
to make sure that your video is
optimized
creating a YouTube channel
to create a YouTube channel you have to
go to your YouTube homepage and then you
click on the little photo here that you
will see when you locked into your
Google account
when you click on the settings it will
take you to the screen where you will be
able to click on the button see all my
channels or create a new channel
so let's click on this and now you will
see the screen where you can enter the
name of your Channel
and in this case I'm going to call it
react for Russia
I click create and you will then get to
the page where you can start customizing
your Channel
if I click on customize Channel I see
the blank version of the YouTube channel
where you can add your logo your channel
art and where you can add a channel
description
so let's start with adding a short
Channel description
welcome to my YouTube channel of Riyadh
farasha
when we're done with that we can add a
logo to do that you click on the little
pencil icon it will actually take you to
the brand page of your Google account
click on edit and you can upload a photo
click on upload photo and here we are
going to upload this image
once it has uploaded the photo you can
play a bit with the size of it you can
move it up a bit if you want so I'm
going to move it so I only show the
mosaic
I click done and then my brand page has
been updated with the image
if I now go back to the YouTube page and
I do a refresh you will see that the
image has been added to the YouTube page
I can do the same for the channel art
click on the channel art you need to be
aware that you don't have a lot of space
to play with for your image so you need
to make sure that you have a horizontal
photo that will show enough of what you
want to cover in the banner
a nice feature is that it will show you
how it will look on the desktop how it
will look on the TV and how it will look
on the mobile
and if you're not happy with it you can
adjust the crop a little so I can zoom
in and then move it up
so at least I see a little bit of the
mountains and a bit of the mosque on the
photo
when I'm happy with it I click select
and then you will see that you have
uploaded a banner
and you are now ready to start
optimizing your YouTube channel
checking the YouTube channel settings
so the first thing you want to check
when you start optimizing your channel
is your settings of the channel
you can access the channel settings by
clicking on the little cartwheel on the
top right
click on that and this will take you to
the basic privacy settings
you can keep your videos private
subscriptions private your saved
playlist private you can customize the
layout of your channel and you can show
the discussion tab
so you can basically switch all these
options on or off and you can also
translate your channel info the basic
settings you can find on this little
screen but there are more options in the
account settings and in the advanced
settings
so let's look first at the options in
the account settings this is where you
can look at what you're going to share
on YouTube
you can look at your connected apps for
instance in this section
do you want any other apps to connect
with your YouTube you can also set how
to connect your TV to the YouTube
channel you can connect your YouTube to
a particular TV device and you can look
at your Billings and payments and your
playback and performance this is where
you can control your video experience
you can show annotations and in video
notifications you can also set that the
captions are always on or when that's
available Show automatic captions by
speech recognition
you can also set the notifications for
your YouTube so you can receive emails
about your activities if you want
updates from YouTube or notifications
around Channel subscriptions and other
notifications like recommended videos if
I go back to the main Channel page and
I'm going back into the settings I can
then also go into the advanced settings
for my channel in the advanced settings
I can check the country that I'm based I
can set keywords for my channels I can
disable interest-based ads and I can
link my AdWords account I can activate
Channel recommendations and display the
subscriber account this is also where
you can integrate your YouTube channel
with your Google analytics so look a bit
further up here I can see The Branding
options that I have so I can add a
watermark to my Channel videos I can
also set defaults for uploading my
videos this can be quite handy if you
have standard text that you want to use
for every video
and I can set some standard tags for
instance this can be helpful when you
upload lots of videos so the standard
defaults are already set and then
finally here you see the status and
features of your channel this is where
you have all the different options that
you have with your channel and you can
check what the status is the different
elements that are enabled and elements
that you are eligible for and the
elements that you are ineligible for for
example we're not eligible for
monetization because we haven't signed
up for it and we haven't passed the
requirements for this
so for all these things we can see
whether we have it enabled whether we
are eligible or whether we are
ineligible
and that's all there is to the settings
so let's go back now to the channel by
clicking on the logo and we can then
start looking at the optimization of our
Channel
how to optimize your YouTube channel to
start customization and optimization of
your YouTube channel you have to go to
the standard Channel page and click
customize Channel
here you see the structure and elements
of your YouTube channel an important
feature is that you can look at your
channel as yourself
as a new visitor or as a returning
visitor
you can set a video at the top of your
YouTube channel which will change
whether you're a new visitor or a
returning visitor
but let's first look at the different
elements of your YouTube page that you
can change
you can add videos to your channel you
can add playlists to your channel and
you can connect with other channels you
can manage your discussions and you can
put more info in your about section
this is also where you can link to your
other social media Pages these will show
on your channel Banner and you can
feature other channels that you would
like to promote on your YouTube channel
so you start with adding some videos to
your channel click on videos and you see
this channel has no video yet
remember how we uploaded a video in
YouTube by clicking this little plus
icon and we say upload video we can then
select a video that we want to upload
let's take this short video at some
basing settings and set some tags
once the video is processed you can then
publish it on your channel page
and if you go back to your Channel
you will see that the video has been
added so that's how you can upload
videos to your Channel
you can then look at playlists here you
can add a playlist to your channel a
playlist is a group of videos around a
particular topic and then you can
feature those playlists as chapters in
your YouTube channel it makes it very
easy to organize your videos
to create a playlist I click on new
playlist I give it a title Marrakesh in
this case
edit if I click create and then your
playlist has been created then you need
to add videos to your playlist
if you go back to the video and play it
to get into editing mode then in the
settings of the video I can say to which
playlist I want to add this video
I select a playlist that I just created
and click done and I save it and then I
have added a video to my playlist
so if I now go back to my YouTube
channel I can click on playlists and
there is my Marrakesh playlist and it
currently has one video
I can add channels so I can link to any
other channel I may have
I can manage my discussions and I can
manage my about page in this section as
well
I can activate business inquiries so
people can send me an email through my
channel
I can specify my location and I can add
my social media links who will then show
up in my YouTube channel Banner
you can also add featured channels for
instance I want to add the social media
examiner YouTube channel I can add that
and I can click done and then it will
show in the featured channels
if I'm happy with the settings I can go
back to my channel and then you see what
we've done through the channel right now
we've got our first video we have our
feature Channel and we have our playlist
so this is how I can optimize my YouTube
channel
one more thing I would like to show you
if I click customize Channel
then I can see here the featured content
which will show up on the channel for
either returning visitors or new
visitors
if I click here on feature content and
then I pick for instance the video that
I just uploaded then this is how it will
show
I can add a heading for this content so
for example I can say feature
presentation and I click save
and now you see I have a feature video
for the returning visitors
I can also do this for new visitors I
can create a channel trailer for
instance I pick this video and then I
click save and that's how it will show
for new visitors so these are the basic
things you need to look at when you want
to optimize your YouTube channel
YouTube channel views and subscribers
now that we know how to edit and
optimize your videos and your YouTube
channel we will turn our attention to
how to grow views and subscribers on
your Channel
first there is your channel optimize
your channel page write a compelling
Channel description use a great Channel
logo and a banner and create a channel
tagline
then there are your videos make an
awesome Channel trailer video publish
long videos of 10 minutes and more
promote videos in your end screen add a
branded Watermark and add a subscribe
button and enter videos with a strong
call to action thirdly there is your
channel management reply to every
comment and hard grade contents
and finally promote your Channel
embed YouTube videos in blog posts and
promote your channel in ebooks webinars
presentations and Lead magnets doing all
these things right will certainly help
you in growing views and subscriptions
to your Channel
tube buddy is a great tool that can help
you in growing your video fuse and your
channel subscriptions
it's a Chrome browser extension and it
adds a layer of functionality on top of
your YouTube channel
it has features that focus on SEO
promotion and analytics and it also
tracks the video rankings of your videos
but also the videos of your competitors
it's a great tool to find keywords for
your videos and you can go to your
competitor video and check what tags
they have set and use these as keywords
for your videos
it also helps you in publishing videos
on your channel you can schedule videos
to be published and added to playlists
you can make bulk updates to your videos
including the descriptions and it also
helps you to create eye-catching
thumbnails
factors that make a great video of
course it's not only the optimization of
the video that makes the video
successful it is also about the video
itself done well you can use your iPhone
to make highly professional Cinema
quality videos that are being watched by
millions as unsane a feature movie from
film director Stephen Soderberg proved
let me give you some tips how to make
great video think about composition
point of view and Lighting First
composition is about how you place the
different elements in the scene put some
thought into this use the rule of thirds
and focus on people's eyes I'll explain
the rule of thirds shortly point of view
is the angle you are using of the lens
of the camera in relation to the subject
be creative with this use a low angle or
a high angle and change these regularly
lighting can make the difference to a
good or a bad video always be aware of
your light source and also know that
daylight is the best light source there
is but different times during the day
can give different shadow effects in the
video for instance noon sunlight creates
unflattering Shadows whereas a cloudy
day can produce more softer lights using
the right equipment is also very
important in shooting great videos
obviously your phone can fulfill most of
the camera requirements like shooting
video and recording sounds and it will
give you an acceptable level of quality
make sure the resolution settings on
your phone are on 4K or 1080 HD and it's
set at 24 30 or 60 frames per second
avoid zooming avoid backlights and use
both hands if you want to up the quality
to professional then you may want to use
a high quality DSLR camera an additional
gear like a tripod and a microphone
the road leveler microphone is a great
mic that you can attach to your iPhone
and your color it gives excellent
quality sounds and you can overlay that
sound over the sound file of your video
earlier I promised you I was going to
explain the rule of thirds they are part
of the basic rules of composition the
rule of thirds is a compositional rule
that suggests dividing the image into
thirds and placing the subject on one of
those sides instead of in the center
it is one of the most important
composition techniques used by
professional photographers
but there are others as well for
instance using balance and symmetry in
your video or apply leading lines in
your video
these lines direct a fewer to a
particular section of the screen finally
as I mentioned before a simple rule is
to focus on the eye it gives a point of
focus
monetizing your YouTube channel
there are various ways that you can make
money with YouTube but it depends on how
strong your subscriber base is and how
many views you get on your channel if
you are qualified then you can
participate in Google's AdSense program
which means that you can get revenue
from ads being placed before or during
your videos when people watch them
this works very well and many Publishers
on YouTube get a significant Revenue
stream through this channel
you can also try to get sponsorships for
your channel this can take the form of
brand or product sponsorship for which
you will get paid
you can also look into affiliate
marketing with this you can advertise
products from your affiliate Partners on
your channel and you would get a
percentage of the sales that comes in
through your channel and finally if
people like your videos then they may
commission you to make videos for them
as I mentioned before you need to have a
strong channel to qualify for Google's
AdSense program which means you need to
have at least 4 000 watch hours in the
previous 12 months and 1 000 subscribers
to sign up for AdSense you need to go to
the old version of creative studio and
click on channel and monetization you
can set the monetization preferences and
which video you want to run the ads with
if you qualify Google will then approve
your request and you are ready to start
earning money with YouTube here are the
key takeaways of this lesson YouTube has
recently launched a new version of
YouTube studio called YouTube Studio
beta getting few and subscribers on your
YouTube channel is based on your video
the quality and optimization of your
channel and how you promote your Channel
composition lighting and point of view
are important contributors to the
quality of your video
and you can make money with YouTube
through advertising sponsorships and
commissioned work welcome everyone this
is Rob Sanders and welcome to today's
webinar Youtube advertising So today
we're going to talk about YouTube
advertising so thanks again I'm Rob
Sanders and I'm with simply learn and
let's get started and we're going to do
a little role playing here and let's
just say you're an Advertiser and you're
not sure where you want to advertise
your products you have a product that
you want the entire world to see well if
you want to advertise your products and
let's just say you have some really good
video of your product that you want to
get out there really there's no other
place to look to than one place in
particular is YouTube hence the reason
why we're doing this webinar because
today we're going to talk about all
things YouTube advertising and for those
that don't know you YouTube is owned by
Google and a lot of what you're going to
do is advertise on YouTube via Google
ads So today we're going to talk about
YouTube advertising and we're going to
focus somewhat on Google ads so buckle
up and let's get started with why is
advertising on YouTube a good idea so
why is it a good idea well if you
haven't been on YouTube of late you
should check it out youtube.com and just
take a look at the vastness of videos
that are on YouTube now YouTube is a
video platform but if it was a search
engine it'd be the second largest search
engine in the world only behind its
parent company Google so it's a very big
platform with a lot of videos and hence
there's some good search functionality
on YouTube so you can look at it as a
search engine there's 1.9 billion and
growing logged in visitors on a monthly
basis so you have a lot of people that
go to YouTube and watch videos on a
daily basis okay it has local versions
and more than 91 countries so if you're
an Advertiser who's focusing on a
specific Market or you're in a different
Market with a different language you
have 91 different options to hone in on
okay so a little bit more about YouTube
here and why is advertising on YouTube a
good idea well most YouTube users are on
mobile almost 70 percent almost three
quarters of those that you use YouTube
use it from their mobile device which is
staggering but not so staggering
considering most people in the world now
have mobile phones or mobile devices and
most people use their mobile devices for
multiple reasons and watching videos is
one of those reasons so mobile
advertisements receive viewer attention
83 percent of the time so what do we
mean by that well on YouTube we have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
people who are watching those videos so
if a lot of people are engaged and
watching a video on YouTube and you're
advertising on that particular video
well then you're going to get some
attention and so that attention has to
be in the 80 percentile okay so a lot of
people are going to you know pay
somewhat attention to your ad and it's
their secret video ads have proven to be
more effective and engaging creating
greater impact and and that's just not
on YouTube I mean that's that's on
Facebook that's on other platforms like
Twitter Instagram so video is an
engaging way to communicate it's a lot
better than traditional texts it's a lot
better than say a display Banner because
it's engaging people are going to watch
what you have to say and if they like it
they're going to share they're gonna
comment on it they're gonna subscribe
there's a lot of things that people can
do when it comes to video advertising so
video helps expand and your digital
reach so basically if you are running
those Tech stats and display ads well
having video kind of adds some more
Arsenal to your advertising portfolio so
to speak so if you're running just those
text ads and swipe banners that's fine
that's great because you can reach a lot
of people but having video just adds
another piece of the element and because
video is so engaging you might find that
even for yourself if you're advertising
different types of ads video display or
text you'll find that you know video
does have really really expansive reach
to a particular audience and the other
thing here about YouTube is YouTube
helps to find a relevant audience for
your ads using Advanced targeting so
just like anything else that we've
talked about here at simply learn when
it comes to advertising whether that be
Facebook or Instagram or Google ads we
can really hone in on our audience here
and that's really important and we'll
get to that later because when you're
advertising you want to make sure your
ad is in front of the right people and
if we're talking about video and we're
talking about high engagement if you
have your video in front of a really
relevant audience then chances of that
audience engaging are going to be even
greater and then YouTube and video ads
themselves provide provides a situation
that can be customized to fulfill your
marketing goals and so what do we mean
by that so basically YouTube allows us
some additional features where we can
customize our ads so meaning if our
marketing goal is to just get our ad in
front of millions of people well that's
not a problem if our marketing goals get
people who you know we want to convert
well we can customize our marketing goal
towards that as well so just like on
Facebook and some of these other
platforms we've talked about YouTube is
no different and so we could set
specific marketing goals uh for our
video ads some other good pointers to to
talk about here with YouTube so with
YouTube just like on Google ads we can
enable running cost-effective campaigns
and what do I mean by cost-effective
well meaning we can really watch our
budget we can measure how how much it
costs for 1 000 people to watch our
video we can measure how much it costs
for somebody to click on our video ad we
can measure the cost of when somebody
clicks on our video ad and converts how
much does that costing us so you can
really run cost-effective campaigns even
on YouTube and YouTube helps determine
how successful your ads with Advanced
analytics so not only do we have
analytics on the YouTube side of the
house but we also have analytics on
Google ads and so we can really hone in
and use both platforms to really figure
out exactly how our ads are performing
and then ads that I've reported a 500
growth in views of the Channel's other
videos so basically you can see growth
in view just by advertising on YouTube
so let's get in now to what are the
types of ads you can run on YouTube so
we discussed all the benefits of YouTube
we can go on for another two or three
hours because there are plenty of
benefits but I think you get the point
of you know YouTube being a place where
you can grow measure and reach a custom
audience so you're already sold on
YouTube now let's talk about those types
of ads you want to run on YouTube so
depending on what goal you want to
achieve with your ads there are
different types of AD formats available
on YouTube so our first set of ads
evolve around building brand awareness
and app recalls so if you're in the
business of promoting your product or
your brand or your service then these
are the type of ads you want to run on
YouTube building brand awareness and AD
recalls because what it does is it's
really going to get your ad out there
and front of thousands and millions of
people lots of eyeballs lots of
Impressions impressions are the number
of times your ad was seen so ads
centered around brand awareness are
really ads that are going to put you out
there in front of a large number of
people with the goal of potentially
attracting new customers and ensuring
your brand is on top of their mind so
top of funnel brand awareness is always
introducing the brand getting people
familiar with the brand and getting them
to your website so that you can
introduce them to your brand and service
and product so that's the whole idea
behind the ads we're going to introduce
behind the goal building brand awareness
and AD recalls so let's take a look at
what those are so we can build brand
awareness and add recalls so we call
these these types of ads true view for
reach okay so when we say true view
meaning our ads go into pair and front
of a video and we want to make sure that
that adds in front of a lot of people so
skippable ads that will enable your
brand to reach as many people in your
target audience as possible at the most
efficient price so the whole idea is
we're trying to build brand awareness
then we could set it up on YouTube so
there are ad appears before other videos
and that's going to ensure that our ad
is going to show up in a lot of places
based on the audience we Target and if
we can get our ad in front of a lot of
people a lot of targeted people at an
efficient price then how can you say no
to that so these ads are skippable have
an open video length and their bidding
is based on cost per 1000 Impressions so
cost per 1000 Impressions CPM means that
you're paying YouTube for every 1 000
people that looked at your ad okay so
that's what cost per 1000 Impressions or
CPM means that you're paying YouTube not
when somebody clicks on your ad but one
one thousand Impressions occur and
oppression is when somebody looks at
your ad and so that's what you're going
to be paying YouTube you're going to be
paying for 1 000 views or Impressions
basically okay so the ads are skippable
but they have an open video length and
it's based on eyeballs so that's the
whole goal there when it comes to Brand
awareness you want to go with a CPM
model that ensures you're getting your
ads in front of lots of people to
accumulate Impressions and pay by
Impressions so this is what the ad looks
like and now we're going to talk about
the type 2 ad that you can run on
YouTube and we call these bumper ads so
they're non-skippable ads with which you
can share your Brand's message in six
seconds to drive reach and impact so
we've all seen these videos before and
I'm going to share an example with you
here when you're on YouTube you really
can't get to that video that you really
want to watch until you watch a few
seconds of that video ad and so that's
what these bumper ads are they allow you
to really make sure that your ad is in
front of that target audience still it's
still pay by Impressions but you know
that your ad is going to run for a few
seconds and the idea behind that is
really you want to get your message out
there and it really does help to drive
reach and impact and so let's take a
look at an example on YouTube of what a
bumper ad looks like so here's an
example of a bumper ad on YouTube again
it's only six seconds but this example
is pretty popular on YouTube it's Been
viewed a lot and we're just gonna take a
quick look at this video here this video
has six seconds but the whole point is
to really look at the ads purpose and so
if we hit play
[Music]
so that was it that was the ad six
seconds long it appears in in front of
other videos as an advertisement and the
whole point of these bumper ads is
really you have to get your message out
there quickly because the video is going
to start and you want to really make
sure that your message is being
delivered and you want to keep in this
case maybe keep users guessing as to
what it is and so this is why it's a
highly effective ad you know you got a
diver jumping off a diving board into a
pool that is basically drying up over a
period of time and so for curiosity the
old saying is curiosity kills the cat a
lot of people are probably going to
click on that ad to figure out what is
the subject what are we all talking
about here and really the point of the
the video was to bring awareness about
global warming but that's it that's a
six second bumper at example and you
really if you're gonna run bumper ads
you want to make sure that you your
message out there so it has to have
really high impact okay so again they're
non-skippable they have to be of six
seconds and their bidding is based on
again cost per 1000 Impressions so it
gives you an a chance to get that ad out
there in front of a lot of people again
you're paying on a CPM model you're
paying Google for every 1000 impression
okay so that's could be 1 000 different
eyeballs looking at that ad so if it's
high impact you know if it's
non-skippable then chances are you can
get you know some clicks some some
eyeballs over to your YouTube channel or
to your landing page on your website so
let's take a look at this one from
Alaska Airlines better yeah let's take a
look at this example from Airbnb I found
it to be a little bit more impactful
than the Alaska Air ones so let's take a
look at this example actually so we went
on vacation with a toe different and
left with a cannonballer
okay so high impact ad great ad by
Airbnb really impactful we went on a
vacation kids playing you have your logo
on the bottom right corner of the video
and you know it gets people excited
about travel so similar to the Alaska
Airlines which we didn't look at this
one is just as good high impactful you
know getting people to you know react
within six seconds isn't exactly a very
easy thing to do so you got to make sure
these videos really resonate within the
time frame that you have so let's take a
look at type 3 here so we're talking
about reservation of 15 to 20 seconds so
these particular ads can span up to 20
seconds to increase reach and make a
lasting impression so unlike the bumper
ads which are six seconds long these
reservation ads tend to run a few
seconds longer up to 20 seconds okay so
they're also non-skippable and like I
said can be up to 20 seconds and bidding
is based based on a fixed CPM and what
do we mean by fixed CPM well if you're
bidding on a regular CPM model meaning
that you're paying Google for every 1000
Impressions that number could be
variable what you pay Google in this
case the fixed CPM is fixed at a certain
rate it could be you know ten dollars
for every one thousand Impressions
twenty dollars it really depends on
where you're advertising and who else is
advertising so let's take a look at some
examples of a reservation ad on YouTube
up to 15 to 20 seconds long so here is
an example of a 15 second ad you know
also called a trueview ad so you can see
this ad is going to run for about 15
seconds before the video actually plays
it's non-skippable and so let's just
play this ad
who can paint the corners is known as a
red brand
a GMC we get that
everyone loves that kind of precision
this is GMC okay so you could see the ad
itself uh ran a little bit longer than
your traditional or your six second
non-skippable version and the 15 second
you know allows you to get you know more
of the message out there still high
impactful but allows us to get the
message out there
um with a little bit longer of a video
and that's non-skippable so it's so
going to run for its entirety up to 15
20 seconds before the video actually
starts playing so let's now turn our
attention to the fourth type of AD you
can run on YouTube and that four type is
an outstream video ad and so these ads
are going to reach users wherever they
watch regardless of the site or
application so the whole point of the
outstream we want to be able to get our
ads out there regardless of the site or
application okay so these ads are also
non-skippable and they could be 15 to 20
seconds long and their bidding is based
on on viewable cost per 1000 Impressions
and so what do we mean by viewable cost
per 1000 Impressions what we mean by
viewable cost per 1000 Impressions is
basically if you're paying for ad
Impressions measured as viewable you you
can use this model and basically what
that means that an ad is counted as
viewable when 50 of your ad shows on
screen for one second or longer or plays
continuously for two seconds or longer
so there's some criteria about the
viewable but you're definitely paying
for Impressions you're just paying when
those Impressions showcase the ad 50 or
longer or for one second or longer for
you know other type of video ads or it
plays continuously for two seconds or
longer for video ads so if a play is in
short if it plays for longer than two
seconds then you're going to pay for
that impression and so that's going to
count as an impression and that's
viewable for 1 000 Impressions so if you
get your basically your ad to show for
two seconds or longer then then that's
going to count as an impression so for
example with the viewable CPM for
example if you bid
um 1000 viewable Impressions and you pay
for Impressions that are measured as
viewable and add is counted as viewable
again when 50 of your ad shows on the
screen for one second or longer for
display ads and two seconds or longer
for video edits so uh so that's
basically what it's about so really the
key number here with viewable CPM is two
seconds or longer that's the difference
between regular 1000 Impressions CPM and
viewable 1000 Impressions vcpm so let's
talk about the next type of AD format
you can run on YouTube and the next one
is Masthead and so Masthead is unique in
that basically they only run for 24
hours okay so and they run on YouTube's
homepage so you can imagine the amount
of reach that you can have by
advertising on YouTube's homepage so
they're highly visible okay they can run
on multiple devices desktop app mobile
and basically these ads sit at the top
of YouTube's homepage so their fixed
cost per day pricing involved and so the
best thing to do is to contact YouTube
if you're interested in advertising on
YouTube's homepage so that's the
Masthead advertising and basically these
ads are non-skippable they have an open
length and again their bidding is based
on fixed price per day so here's an
example of what the Masthead looks like
on the home page so you can see here
this is that GMC ad okay you can see
that they have video supported with a
banner and you know call call to action
out there and so what YouTube is
actually experimenting with are you know
different ways for advertisers to buy
Masthead ads okay so it's you know these
ads are very prominent so it's it's
basically YouTube is now offering the
option uh to buy mousethead ads on a
cost per 1000 impression basis so
they're playing around with that cost
format so just keep in mind that this is
a recent change by YouTube so
traditionally it's cost per day but now
they're actually offering the option for
advertisers to buy a Masthead ad on a
CPM basis so just keep that in mind you
do you do have the option here so at the
end of the day if you're interested in
math test ads and having your ads show
up on YouTube's homepage for 24 hours I
would still contact Google and ask them
about hey I want to pay cost more 1000
Impressions so YouTube is actually
offering up that option on pricey model
so so the second set of ads we're going
to focus in on are centered around this
strategy of growth consideration and
interest and the whole idea behind
growth consideration and interest is
really we want to get our ads in front
of people who could be potential
customers but we want to influence them
okay we want to influence them at a
point in time when they when we think
they're going to be most receptive to
our message so that really means getting
our ad out in front of the Right
audience at the right time because the
message we put out there is going to be
centered around you know getting them to
not only take notice of our brand
potentially take action so it's moving
our audience a little further down that
funnel so really growth consideration
and interest it's all about placing your
ad your message in front of that
potential customer when you think
they're going to be most receptive to
the messaging you're putting out so
that's what growth consideration and
interest is so let's go back and look at
let's talk a little bit more about those
true view ads so trueview ads are one of
the most popular ways of advertising on
YouTube so if you're interested in you
know getting growth getting leads
getting conversions you might want to
think about some true view ads because
basically these ads can run before
during or after videos on YouTube or you
can run them on video partner sites and
applications again if you're interested
in driving not just brand awareness but
you know clicks to your site so if
you're interested in driving impact for
your brand of products you might want to
focus on the true View and stream ads
again these are the traditional ads
you've probably seen before on YouTube
that run before during or after a video
and these ads are skippable so you're
likely to have seen the skip ad uh call
to action button they have an open video
length in their video is based on cost
per view so you're paying when somebody
views your ad and so what what's what
does that mean cost per view well let's
break that down cost per view bidding is
the default way to set the amount you'll
pay for a true view video ad so when are
you actually paying well you're paying
when somebody views your video and but
there's a threshold here so a view is
counted on YouTube when someone watches
30 at least 30 seconds of your video ad
or if it's shorter than 30 seconds and
let's just say it's 20 seconds then
that's going to be considered a view so
30 seconds is the number here you need
to be concerned about when you're
running a cost per view model so if you
have a video that's one minute long and
they watch 30 seconds it's considered a
view and that's what you're going to pay
you're going to pay cost per view so
that's what the cost per view model is
and that's the really the default model
with trueview ads whether that be before
the video during the video or after the
video it's it's cost per view so let's
talk about the other type of trueview AD
and that's the true view Discovery and
so basically What trueview discovery is
is your ads are placed in YouTube search
results next to related videos or on the
YouTube homepage so you're getting your
ad discovered more or less you know
throughout YouTube and including the
YouTube homepage so here's an example of
what that looks for looks like and so
let's jump over to YouTube and take a
look at that so if I do type in let's
just say surfing I may scroll down and I
may see some ads I may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have ADD next to it and so that's
when you know your ad is being
discovered on YouTube and so here in
this example we don't see any ads
showing up here so remember those true
review Discovery ads are going to have
something with the ad next to them that
way you know it's an advertisement and
they're going to be found in the search
results on YouTube's homepage or any
page where you're actually searching
okay third set of AD types center around
driving action and so the whole point of
driving action is getting that potential
customer to actually take action on the
ad that they see so in the case of
videos we're going to have some call to
action stronger call to action to get
these folks over to the website to
purchase or download or you know sign up
for a newsletter or do something you
want them to do in terms of your
business model so if your business model
is selling a product then the whole
point of driving action on your ad is
getting in to buy your product we want
so the whole point of driving action is
make it easier for customers to take
meaningful actions that you can measure
so the ads we're going to introduce are
centered around getting potential
customers to take action okay so that's
what driving action is further down the
funnel and getting folks to react to
your ad so that they can take the action
that's aligned with your business
talking about true view ads now and so
again these ads Discovery can show up on
search results on YouTube's home page uh
you have your traditional in-stream
trueview ads where they show up before
during or after and then here you have
true view for action and so these true
refer action ads are video ads to drive
any action that's important to your
business so again it goes back to that
marketing strategy so the ads we looked
at on early on were about Impressions so
a lot of the cost models for a lot of
the ad types were cost per 1000
impression and notice now that you know
it's it's now cost per view for trueview
ads and you want to be on a different
model when your marketing strategy is
more aligned with getting people to take
action that's important to your business
for example shopping or buying something
or getting a quote or or downloading
something so if that's your marketing
goal you want to go with a true view for
Action if that's what's important your
business because these ads are intended
to get users to interact with a
clickable button that leads to your site
so that's the whole idea behind trueview
for Action type ads okay so these are
skippable they have an open video length
and their bidding is based on cost per
acquisition so CPA different cost model
so let's now talk about what CPA is so
the cost per acquisition model is in
this case since we're trying to drive
action we're going to pay when somebody
actually takes that action so somebody
actually does shop and they spend twenty
dollars then basically you're gonna pay
for that acquisition so basically if
it's to download something whatever it
costs for you to get that person over
and they actually download that's what
you're going to pay so cost per
acquisition is really a model based on
action so when somebody actually
performs that action that's when you're
actually going to pay Google so that's
what CPA is and that's what the YouTube
trueview for Action ads are all about
trying to drive action so let's talk
about the universal app campaign for
video and so this is all about driving
action as well so these ads promote your
app on YouTube so way your ads are more
likely to be clicked and your app
downloaded so again targeting an
audience and really it's about you know
getting people to look at your
application your mobile app so that's
what these ads are all about they're
about promoting your mobile app on
YouTube okay so these ads are skippable
okay they have an open video length Okay
meaning you can make them as long as you
want and again their bidding is cost per
acquisition but you also have some
additional models as well so we already
talked about what cost per acquisition
is because this is a actional based ad
so we want people to do something like
download or app but you also have
another cost model here cost per install
and you only pay when that person who
watches or sees that ad clicks on it and
actually does install the app okay you
also have another model that you can
apply here and that's the return on ad
spend and a return on ad spend basically
is you're asking Google hey I want to
make sure that if I'm going to run this
type of AD I'm getting my return on
investment meaning if I spend a hundred
dollars am I getting a hundred and one
dollars back so that's the return on ad
spend that's a cost per install and a
cost per acquisition so you have three
models here for the univ reversal app
campaign about some important metric for
YouTube so we've thrown around a lot of
different cost models when we talked
about the different types of advertising
you can do on YouTube and so with that
there's a lot of metrics so let's go
through some of these metrics here you
have views clicks you have view rate so
you have all these different types of
metrics and for some of you it could be
confusing so what am I need to look like
look at what do I need to measure so it
really does come down to you know what's
important to your business that's always
first and foremost but here we listed
some of the most common metrics
available to you with YouTube Okay so
let's go through some of these and
basically a view is just it shows the
number of times people watched or
engaged with your video ad so a view
rate is basically the number of views or
engagement you're at receives and the
number times your ad is shown okay so
divided by the number of times your ad
was shown into the number of engagements
so if your ad was shown a hundred times
and you had one like or one click for
example then that would be one percent
so average cost per view is the average
amount you pay whenever your watch is 30
seconds of your video so remember when
you're on a cost per view model remember
30 seconds is the magic number so if
your video is only 25 seconds then
remember that's going to be the view so
it's got to be minimum or maximum 30
seconds if your video is under 30
seconds it's 25 seconds or 20 as an
example then it's still going to count
as a view if it's a minute and somebody
watched at least 30 seconds of it then
that's going to count as a view so just
keep in mind 30 seconds is the magic
number here for the view so if somebody
watches at least 30 seconds of your
video or engages with your video that
would be a cost per view so that's the
average amount you're going to pay and
watch time is basically it measured the
total amount of time people watched your
video ads shown in seconds okay so it's
the total amount of time so it gives you
an idea of how many minutes total your
video is run so let's focus on clicks so
clicks is a common metric across the
board it shows the number of times
people actually clicked on your video
not to be confused the view to view is
the number of times your video was
actually watched a click is something
also measurable and it's when somebody
actually clicked on it so it's an
indicator for how well your ads are
doing with those who see it and so you
know we want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type video ads if we're running those
action at type ads or Universal app ads
we're going to want people to take
action okay if you're running ads just
for Impressions that's one thing so
clicks is an important metric depending
on the type of video ad you're running
so click the rate is the number of
clicks you you receive from your ad
divided by the number of times the ad
was shown so my ad was shown a hundred
times and I received one click then
that's one percent click-through rate so
let's talk about engagement and
engagement is the number of clicks on
interactive elements such as icons in
your video ad okay so that's what an
engagement is here the number of clicks
on interactive elements and then if we
look at engagement rate then any clicks
on an interactive element that we
receive is going to be divided by the
number of times the outer shell so
that's why we have engagement rate as
well so we want people to engage with
our video is there something that
they're doing on the video if so then
what's the rate at which they're
engaging earned views sets a number of
views who have seen subsequent videos on
your Channel or watch Pages after seeing
your ads so watch Pages or videos on
your channel if you've ever seen those
after seeing your ad then that's going
to be calling earned view so somebody
seen your ad and was impacted by what
they saw if we look back at the examples
we've shown earlier on with the global
warming or the GMC or the Airbnb ads you
know if I saw those ads and I said man
that's really a cool ad or that's really
good message I'm going to go over to
that that watch page or I'm going to go
over to that channel and see what other
videos they have when you do that that's
an earned View and then if you can get
an earned view you're probably going to
get an earned subscriber because it's
the number of viewers who subscribe to
your channel after seeing your ad so
again going back to any of the ads that
you've ever seen if you've ever gone
over to their Channel and then subscribe
to the channel that's an earned
subscriber so your video ad is doing
something for you it's in this case it's
getting you a subscriber so let's talk
about how to create a YouTube ad so this
is going to require some access to
Google ads and we'll go over that in a
few minutes here but first we need to
think about setting up a campaign and
setting up a campaign goal okay what's
the goal of our campaign to get eyeballs
yeah we want to pay cost for 1000
Impressions or we want to run some
actionable type ads to get people over
to our website so that really is step
one we need to identify what the goal of
our campaign is then we need to create
the ad so we want to be able to create a
video ad here that is going to show on
YouTube and to our target audience so or
whether it be a bumper ad that's only
going to be six seconds long we need to
be able to figure out what type of AD we
want to run so here I am in Google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
YouTube we need to make sure that we're
choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads than you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video basically what we're
doing is we're going to tell Google we
want to go ahead and set up some video
ads on YouTube and so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our outstream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to you know move forward
with selecting our ad so you can see
here after I set up my campaign now I'm
just going to go through some of the
settings for my ad and I'm going to give
it a campaign name a budget okay when it
starts or ends the bidding strategy so
again we're going to focus on cost per
1000 Impressions and then here's the
network so this is an important
selection here so we're dealing with
YouTube videos so we also have the
option to select video Partners on the
Display Network so that means that if
you want your video to show on websites
that want to host ads in video format
then you can select this option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on YouTube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so I'm going
to stick with the video Partners okay
YouTube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
here you could see the default is
standard inventory so that means that
this is what Google recommends we want
to show our ads on content that's
appropriate for most ads okay so we can
go expanded or limited so we're going
with the recommended here okay and then
when we go down we're going to have an
ad group so when you create an a
campaign you can have an ad group so
with an ad group that means that we can
have a more or less a video in every ad
group we have but we have to have at
least one ad group so we're going to go
ahead and set up you know this ad group
here and here's where it gets
interesting and important because here
is where we can start targeting our
audience so here we got demographics
okay so we can choose gender age
parental status household income okay we
can focus in on audiences if we want to
so we can we can choose a specific
audience that we've set up we can get
some ideas or browse specific audiences
we could also choose a specific
placement so here you have YouTube
videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our Target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to the
bumper ads and we're looking at about
six seconds and once we do that then
that's pretty much the campaign but I
just want to stress here that when
you're setting it up ahead of time you
want to make sure you identify what the
campaign goal is and then that's going
to align with the type of video you're
going to run and then once you choose
that type of video then it just comes
down to where you want that ad to be and
who you're targeting so it's really
crucial here that you go through these
steps and these options very closely so
because you want your video to show in
front of the ride audience on the right
placement so let's talk about how you
can optimize your YouTube ads so once
you get your campaign set up once you
select your Channel or the type of
videos where you want your ad to be and
you select your target audience and
you're off and running with your video
ad well we're going to give you some
tips here that you can focus on for
optimizing Those ads and so going back
to what I was just saying on the setup
you want to carefully Define your
metrics and goals okay so that's step
one so when you're setting up the
campaign remember you have that option
to choose the type of goal for your
campaign that can be brand awareness it
could be a sale it could be a lead so to
me that's the you know a very critical
step one so you want to make sure you
align your goal with your video and then
the second is track low performing ad
placements so if we just ask Google to
place our video ads anywhere they want
then it's up to us then to go through
and choose the ad placements and remove
them okay so let me show you an example
of what that means so if I'm back in
Google I'm gonna go to my campaign and
I'm going to select placements and here
I can see placements but then I'm going
to select where my ads show and so this
is important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign wrapper so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
your placements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get sales or leads if you're
that placement is not converting sales
or leads then you need to remove or
exclude that placement so it's all done
within the Google ads platform and then
you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't Okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ads all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive okay you can always perform
a b testing on your ads so if you have
one ad version you can create another
one just to see what it which one
performs better testing is always a
positive okay so if you're paying in too
much maybe think about reducing your
bids so if you remember we said a 10 CPM
bit that may be too much maybe we don't
need to pay ten dollars so we can always
reduce our bids at the ad group level so
reduce bids in areas where you see lower
performance so in other words you don't
want to pay a lot for poor performance
you can also use remarketing to
re-engage with customers so if somebody
views your ads and doesn't take action
you can always retarget that person uh
to show your ad another even another ad
format it could be text ads or display
ads but if somebody looked at your video
and they didn't take the action you
preferred them to take then you can
always retarget them with another ad so
that's a good way to optimize okay so we
want to make sure the ad has content
that what viewers would find relevant
okay that really you want to make sure
that your ad is you know is with the end
viewer you don't want to put out an ad
that isn't going to give somebody you
know a good feeling after they've
watched it okay so you want to make sure
viewers find the content relevant so if
they don't find it relevant then that
means your engagement rate and your
engagement is probably going to be low
so you want to take a look at those
metrics that we viewed earlier
engagement rate engagement and if
they're low then you probably need to
look at the content of the ad so try to
make sure your ad conveys your Brand's
message in the first six seconds so
that's why bumper ads to me are so
critical because you've got to get the
entirety of the ad and make it impactful
and so with any AD you run any video ad
you're on you really want to make sure
that that message is conveyed at the
very beginning early as possible
otherwise you know people are going to
be turned off or not engaged and just
going to go ahead and skip it anyway so
you want to make sure you get the
purpose of it right up front and out of
the way okay you can also include Visual
and and auditory components in your ad
that can make it more memorable to the
viewers okay meaning music or other cool
visuals okay so again you want to be
able to play around and test different
ads and you want to be able to you know
measure the ad Performance Based on the
metrics we discussed I mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when I say good quality I mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting or so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a B testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry uh so they're a good
success story on YouTube so super dry
leaned on some YouTube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
September last year 2018 super dry if
you're not familiar with the brand
they're you know centered some Asian
markets European markets and they focus
in on clothing uh all different styles
and sizes and genders uh from jackets to
jeans to t-shirts and so they're a
global brand they really wanted to take
a different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so what
they've done is they set up some
campaigns on YouTube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they wanted want to take
advantage of all the different ad types
that YouTube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to YouTube and let's just take a look
at this one minute ad here 53 second ad
buy Super dry
cakey
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting the
jacket you're pulling the jacket your
play power and pull them you'll take
five in this jacket you'll wanna find
this jacket I washed a jacket
take away 3am plates catch your breath
not your death in this jacket it's the
jacket your cream is
a jacket you're hiding you're vibing
love live and praises
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that's super dry ran
you could see that you know it was it
had some particular goals there and so
super dry is pretty well known so it
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on superdry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
Target Their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the air they had
different jackets both female and male
different gender types so they were
messaging a very broad audience of
gender some younger people is who they
were targeting so younger people tend to
slant on YouTube and so they were able
to get some nice views out of it 4.8
million but the more important thing is
because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a hundred and thirty eight percent
increase in brand lip I mean the jacket
ad so it's a pretty successful campaign
see as well choreographed good audio
good video just well professionally done
and they probably were able to now get a
few more loyal customers under their
belt because of this at alone so that's
the power of video okay so you're able
to know who your target audience is you
can go out and Target them with a cool
video and given that YouTube is vast
then you can really take advantage of a
lot of their ads so what they probably
did again was those true view in stream
ads with a cost per view through a
skippable video ad format may they also
use the shoppable ad format so that is
another option on YouTube so they took
advantage of all YouTube had to offer in
terms of who they were trying to Target
the length of the ad and given that
their product or selling a product or
promoting a product they will take
advantage of the trueview shoppable ad
format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again a based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats
hey guys welcome to this video on
YouTube ideas for 2021 YouTube is the
social media platform that needs new
introduction launched back in the Year
2005 YouTube was a fresh breath of air
for the people who were slowly becoming
aware of the hype that surrounded the
internet several other platforms like
Dailymotion redmi and VMO which
admittedly have their own fans have
tried to stand up against the Behemoth
that is the YouTube and failed slowly
but surely marketers began to realize
the enormous potential that YouTube
offered they could add small
advertisements like they do in the cable
TV they could show banner ads and do
much more and all of the thanks to the
robust advertisement features that
Google already offered if you're not
already sold on why it's important to
advertise on YouTube here are some facts
that might change your mind YouTube has
more than 2 billion users across the
world I've got fraction of that audience
could be shown your product and could
turn from users to customers next
important fact is that 8 out of 10
marketers consider YouTube to be one of
the best platforms to advertise their
products and services followed by that
people watch one billionaires of YouTube
per day as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
YouTube to post content this could be
just videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more 70 of
the YouTube watch time comes from mobile
this means that when you create an
advertisement for YouTube you keep the
mobile users in your mind and finally 90
percent of the people say that they've
discovered new products or brands on
YouTube which means that by posting on
YouTube your brand awareness is highly
likely to increase now let's talk about
the video ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience how your business
or brand operates a creatively made
video on the inner workings of your
business will show off a more human side
of your brand and make you more
relatable to your audience it is also
guaranteed to get you loads of views and
engagement here's an example how Amazon
showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like Amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does this
can help better connect with your
audience here's an example a company
culture video created by GoDaddy the
popular domain register
the video talks about how GoDaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees it
includes interviews of employees talking
about why they enjoy working in GoDaddy
so much and this helps the audience
relate with the company and could also
catch up the interest with some
potential job Seekers next we have the
third idea that is the marketing team a
brand is nothing without the people
working behind it and that's where these
videos come in these videos will help
shine a light on the people who create
the products that the audience knows and
loves this helps create a personal
connection with the audience these
individuals can end up becoming mascots
for your brand
here's an example of Meet the team
focusing on Olympus group the video goes
into the history of mascot makers brand
and the people that make it a grand
success the lighthearted tone of the
video also greatly helps with making it
more relatable now we have number four
product showcase or announcement
a product Showcase Video aims to show
the features and benefits of the Brand's
latest offering to its audience these
short concise videos can inform the
audience about everything they need to
know about the new product or service a
product announcement video on the other
hand can be used to give the audience a
more detailed look into the product or
service than the product showcase it can
include comparisons to older versions or
competitors the aim of such video is to
show customers how the new product works
and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
Apple's iPhone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like
next at number 5 we have event
announcements these videos can build a
hype regarding an upcoming event it will
also give you the opportunity to engage
with your audience and build their
interest
this promo video for the data Innovation
Summit 2020 Hypes up the event posting
the greatest Minds in the tech the most
Innovative companies and much more
the next video idea we have at number
six is the explainer videos these videos
are aimed to tell users how a particular
product or a service works these tend to
be much more useful than wall of text
explaining how something works they also
have an added advantage of simplifying
complex Concepts and features to your
audience for example we have our own
video on digital marketing we cover a
number of different concepts like SEO
social media marketing search engine
marketing and more on a visual Mana
making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number seven we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from these videos
aim to be guides to information complex
Concepts hints tips and tricks relating
to your industry here we have our own
digital marketing course video as an
example unlike the previous example I
mentioned this video goes into much more
detail regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing on that note if you
guys are interested in learning about
digital marketing I suggest you start
from this video it's a great one to get
started with now on the next video idea
at number eight we have the product
tutorial a product tutorial video will
take your audience through the various
features of your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product you can also explain the
best way the product can be used
of how the meditation app headspace
explains the app's usage with an
interesting and creative animated video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine we have the webinar a
webinar thanks to its nature provides
your brand with loads of opportunities
to interact with your audience they are
usually very accessible and easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content after the
session is complete here's an example of
Simply learns webinar where we talk to
the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
Audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost
here's an example of a live stream that
constantly keeps a track of subscribers
increasing for some of the most popular
YouTube channels next at number 11 we
have Ama or ask me anything sessions
the AMA or ask me anything sessions are
usually live streams or pre-recorded
sessions that feature questions
collected from the audience although it
originated from Reddit these videos are
finding a success on YouTube thanks to
the interactivity that it offers these
sessions can also give your audience the
opportunity to interact with you provide
suggestions feedback and much more
here's an example of AMA session with
the actor Matt Damon where questions
covering a wide variety of topics
collected from Reddit were answered by
him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your Niche can go a
long way to grow your audience these
sessions are doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry style world and since this
video can be shared on your channel as
well as theirs you can expose your
channel to a brand new audience here's
an example of an interview between
Marcus Brownlee a popular Tech YouTuber
with Bill Gates the interview covers a
wide variety of topics and maintains a
pleasant theme throughout let's now go
to number 13 testimonials a testimonial
video helped highlight the positive
feedback from a client or a customer
they provide social proof and provide a
unique perspective on your products and
services these videos can greatly help
improve people's trust on your brand
shareability and credibility here's an
example of Simply lunch testimonial
video that covers a learner's Journey as
he crew in his career video thanks to
Simply learn certification a video like
this can be greatly relatable to the
audience and even encourage some of them
to take up a certification let's go to
our next video idea that is the number
14 whiteboard videos a whiteboard video
offers your visually attractive way of
explaining complex Concepts usually this
involves a trained experts breaking
through a complex topic on a whiteboard
nowadays there has also been the trend
of digital whiteboard videos that work
thanks to the visual style and Charisma
of the narrator here's an example of the
Whiteboard video Simply learn created
covering various concepts of social
media marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end
in an interesting example for foldable
flight Channel users submitted their
ideas for paper airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions and saw considerable growth
next we have 16 the lists list videos
are some of the most commonly found
content on YouTube most users enjoy this
type of content thanks to it being small
easily digestible and bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from the
best products techniques and much more
the main advantage of these videos are
they provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst in the year 2021
if you are interested don't forget to
check it out at number 17 we have case
studies case studies talk about how your
product or service have benefited
clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likeable
here's a video that analyzes Coca-Cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
Tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being open for the
first time while these are fairly common
for technology these videos have also
found success in fashion apparel these
videos enable the users to experience
the products for the first time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products here's an example
of PS5 being inboxed by Marcus Brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers and
other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews where tech reviews you
can talk about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you didn't its price and other
practical information and much more
here we have an example of OnePlus 8 Pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or TV episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
Engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable here's an
example of a reaction video involving
teenagers reacting to the latest tech
talk videos these videos usually enable
a large amount of likes comments and
shares today we're going to talk about
how to increase YouTube subscribers so
with YouTube It's All About subscribers
the number of subscribers you have on
YouTube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your YouTube videos so
it's all all about how to get
subscribers and today we're going to
talk about how to get more subscribers
and before we begin let's just show you
what we did at simply learn so if we
look at the past 365 days on our YouTube
channel you can see we started here back
in uh if we look back at March 9 2018 we
had 208 and you can see just over the
course of the year it kept creeping up
creeping up creeping up and creeping up
we've gained you know a significant
number of subscribers over the last year
and what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165 percent over the last year
so you can see it's part of it is about
posting videos because when you post
videos you have people who can watch
those videos we have people watch those
videos you can have engagement and then
when you have engagement you have shares
and people who like it and then other
people will see it so it's kind of a
halo effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase the subscriptions so let's
start out with some of those tips we're
going to start with creating engagement
and formative content so engaging in a
formative content that's where we're
going to start talking today about how
to increase subscriptions then we're
going to talk about publishing videos
frequently so if it's simply learn you
could see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks so another tip we're going to
talk about is how to optimize your
YouTube videos so there's a lot that
goes into optimization but this is a key
key tip to pay attention to because when
it comes to posting publishing videos on
YouTube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the the YouTube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
YouTube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber Watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos and
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our Channel we have to create highly
engage in and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audience okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for I mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on YouTube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on YouTube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the Mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't bear off
course if you Veer off course you're not
going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what I normally do is
you know have an outline and then once I
have the outline then I go ahead and
create my slides if I will or my topics
points I want to talk about and then I
write out those points I want to make
sure I get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session I showed you an
example of Simply learn subscribers over
the past 365 days and so that's what we
want to do we want to be clear but use
examples to to punctuate the content or
the point we're trying to get across so
we want to include sources from high
quality sites so if you're going to use
examples make sure they're from relevant
high quality sites when I make high
quality meaning does your audience know
who that source is or that site if it's
really specific and your audience may
not know then it's probably not high
quality so just keep that in mind always
play to your audience so you want to
start your video with an interesting
hook so again I get back to this example
if you're still watching this then the
hook worked we showed you our
subscriptions we showed you how we grew
over the course of a year you could see
our growth and part of it was posting a
lot of videos with relevant and
informative content and so you see how
we did it so you're paying attention you
want to know how to do it and so part of
what we did is exactly what I'm telling
you now we know who our audience is we
plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks now when we do our
videos we also create original content
so that goes back to planning your
script okay you always want to you know
come across as original and informative
when you do that you're going to be
engaging but if you're leveraging
somebody else's content then the
engaging part may not resonate because
it's not your content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline you know feel free to change up
the outline so the flow makes sense add
visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and Aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
Heavy you know accentuate it balance it
with some images use Simple language and
crisp sentences meaning in don't choose
jargon don't come across and talk above
your audience you always want to talk to
your audience and talk in a language
that they're going to understand so it
goes back to point one if you know who
your audience is you're talking to them
as if they're right in front of you and
not you're above them or they're below
you you want to talk at them so add
cards and screens and pattern interrupts
to engage your audience and so YouTube
cards are just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages interaction by the
viewer okay so you can add up to five
cards which include images text or
clickable links so feel free to play
around with some of these features that
YouTube has to offer to make your
content more engaging so tip two publish
videos frequently so creating and
uploading videos consistently will help
you increase your YouTube subscribers so
suppose you haven't published videos
from more than say a month or two months
it's likely that that audience not going
to subscribe to your channel so think
about YouTube videos as a popular TV
program that comes on once a week when a
new episode comes on based on the
regular schedule it's consistency and
that consistency is what helps your
users stay engaged so for example if I
go back to our YouTube channel you know
what helped us gain subscribers was our
consistency in publishing videos you
could see we were consistent in
publishing a couple of videos a week
every couple of weeks and so this helps
users stay engaged they know when the
video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or YouTube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so I subscribe to
Simply learns Channel I subscribe to
other channels like Google analytics for
example so so anytime Google analytics
publishes a video I get an email that
says Hey Google analytics YouTube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is I'm checking my email and
I'm getting this notification in Gmail
so guess what I can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email I don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to Social
Media examiner YouTube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging I always say start small if you
can do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the YouTube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
you'll find that the more you ramp it up
the more subscribers you're gonna get so
tip three optimize your YouTube videos
so optimizing your videos will help your
content rank higher on YouTube so this
is a give must it's not a given it's a
must you must optimize your videos if
you want people to see them of course if
you don't optimize people aren't going
to see them then people aren't going to
engage and then not subscribe so it's
just kind of a snowball effect so this
is an important tip so I mentioned it at
the beginning when we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos are just not
going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content have more chance to
subscribe to your channel but they're
not going to subscribe if they don't
even watch your video so there is a
snowball effect in play here if we don't
optimize your videos so okay Rob what
are some of the tips to optimize your
YouTube video well let's go through some
of those tips so to ensure your videos
reaches the relevant audience on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description in the video tag okay Rob
what do you mean by title description
and video tag so let's take a look at
that so when you actually create your
YouTube video you're going to have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
going to have an opportunity to put in
the description and you're going to have
an opportunity to add text so those are
the three key areas okay so once you put
in that what it looks like on the front
end is this so if I go back to YouTube
and here you can see another video that
we did about a month ago you could see
what is SEO so if that's our topic
that's our title uh or of the content of
the video then the title of the video is
going to be what is SEO and you can see
we also added in some other content for
the title so what is SEO and how does it
work SEO tutorial for beginners and then
our brand name so we have some content
to work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with descriptions so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here seo seo
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video video and
get found so that's just an example
three of the things you can do to help
optimize your YouTube video so if you
want to watch more on how to optimize
meta tags then I suggest maybe watching
the other video we did on the subject
how to rank YouTube videos so this goes
into more detail about how to optimize
the title The Meta description and The
Meta tags but there's a three quick
fields or areas that you can use to
optimize your video so just something to
keep in mind write a long description
with keywords timestamps and links so
what I mean by timestamps for timestamp
an audience can choose the section of
the video that they want to look for and
then links prefer to include relevant
Links of your other videos so those are
just some additional tips to help keep
your content engaging so remember when
your content is engaging and people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a transcript of
the content of the video so that you can
upload that as well and then add a start
screen and end screen to your YouTube
videos so that way you know it's
somebody plays the video they're going
to see it what it looks like up front
and then the way you finish it they're
going to see an end screen at the end
and so you just don't want to keep it
dark and black and non-descriptive so
according to backlinko using an exact
keyword in your video title can help you
with rankings so high ranking more views
more views more subscribers so that's
what I've been saying all along you need
to get these videos optimized so again
use an exact keyword in your video title
so let's go back again to that video I
just showed you a couple minutes ago
what is SEO so here we started out with
a question what is SEO that's the name
of the title that's one exact title all
of the video that's our exact keyword
okay so what is SEO and how does it work
and then SEO tutorial for beginners so
what is SEO is our exact keyword and
that's part of the video that's the
content of the video that's in the title
and we use it throughout the description
as well so using that exact keyword in
your video title can help with the
ranking so whatever your topic is your
title the video or the topic of the
video included in the title so backlinko
also mentions that there is a moderate
correlation between a Channel's total
subscribers and rankings and so for some
of you this may be common sense it's
just like organic search if you're not
ranking you're not going to get traffic
on YouTube if you're not ranking you're
not going to get eyeballs on your videos
and you're not going to get subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of Simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title match is the title of
the video itself when you're publishing
your description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three Fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize your
YouTube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our YouTube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your views to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great YouTube channel
trailer you also want to add Channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good YouTube channel so let's talk about
some some of these these tips here so we
want to give your audience a preview
what your channel is offering so this is
by hooking your audience with the
trailer so you can create a trailer to
you know just give your audience an idea
of who you are as a brand what kind of
videos you're going to be posting and
give them a kind of a taste of what the
future videos are going to be like okay
you can even tell them your release
schedule in the trailer so you can start
off by saying hey hey guys we're new to
this we're going to be posting one video
a month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking to your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description's short and interesting so
in your channel you want to have a
description of what the channel is all
about what kind of videos you're going
to be posting so in addition to the
trailer you want to write something
short and interesting then we want to
use keywords in our Channel descriptions
just like in the videos with what is SEO
we included what is SEO in the title we
included you know what is SEO in the
description and so we want to be true to
what our channel is so pick keywords not
only include those keywords in the
videos but include them in the channel
description pay attention to the first
100 to 150 characters I have your
channel description because that's
what's shown next your channel on the
search results so for example here you
can see we have a description here
simply learn is one of the world's
leading certification training providers
we partner with companies and
individuals to address and so you can
see those characters 100 to 150 or what
shows up in the channel description when
somebody's trying to understand hey
simply learn just uploaded this video
who is simply learn so you want to write
short interesting Channel description so
that when somebody's first introduced to
your video they could see what your
Brand's all about so in your description
with an appropriate call to action so
short interesting good call to action at
the end of the video a good call to
action would be hey check out our next
video or check out our latest video
something that's going to gauge somebody
and get them to watch one of your videos
so you want to pick interesting channel
art so let's turn our attention to the
simply learn Channel page and here you
can see we recently had reached a
milestone so recently reached the 200
000 K subscribers so 200 000 subscribers
is a big achievement for simply learn we
went ahead and updated our Channel R and
I'm sure we will reach 500k we'll update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while so you have that option in YouTube
to do I mean it's very simple so here
you can see simply learns Channel if we
go home we get all our videos listed
here we got the about us you know
something very short and interesting
about us here's our call to action for
more information visit simply learn so
you want to make sure when you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there put your description in play and
create your first videos and get them
posted up there and optimize them
accordingly okay so this is the other
tips to go with that channel art and
description is a profile picture
relevant to your brand so you always
want to maybe put the the company logo
up there okay so here you can see we
have the company logo at Accurate
relevant Channel keywords so if we go
back to who we are who are we we're the
world's leading certification training
provider okay that's who we are okay we
partner with companies and individuals
so we're all about training and training
is one of our keywords so you can see
let's simply learn we provide online
training and machine learning AWS Amazon
web services devops Big Data digital
marketing project management a lot of
different topics so make sure sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
home page so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have ai
machine learning trending Technologies
cloud computing tutorials devops
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but I
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you can
take a video that maybe hasn't gotten a
lot of views or is it ranked
particularly High maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if I go
back to our YouTube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if I
click on that think wisely most popular
videos so 3 000 likes on this video a
lot of views 250 000 plus views so have
a thumbnail to go along with that
particular video so according to
backlinko YouTube SEO ranking Factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with Higher YouTube search rankings so
Channel key words so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if I go back to our
Channel okay if I go back about us make
sure your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you know I'm
going to come across is qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to create high quality videos for
the end users so let's talk about some
ways in which you can create high
quality videos and so the first is to
avoid any noise in the background so you
want to have a nice quiet atmosphere no
distractions so people can hear you
clearly and only you clearly you want to
use good audio recording equipment
there's plenty of options available on
the internet usually I would recommend
going with something paid not overly
expensive because you get what you pay
for so if you use something free it
might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option so
you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online or it
could be some software just make sure
that you're able to produce good high
quality video and audio so when you do
purchase that audio recording equipment
you want to have something similar to an
input volume meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 1080 pixel size okay
that's HD and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that's probably going to come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional not high def so
you want to create a high def video and
1080 is about the minimum you want to go
and then you want to plan your video
script before filming so it goes back to
some of the other points I made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
Fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professionals so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump Cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to accentuate your points and
then set up a green background for
recording again this is for you know
making sure that the video part of it
comes across in good quality and
stabilize your video recordings with a
tripod that way you're not moving your
video camera camera all around and again
it's coming across the shaky and poor
quality shoot horizontal videos you
don't want to go vertical it tends to
cut the screen so you want to stay
horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software I can't
State this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
I would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
the very least review your work before
publishing I just said it a minute ago
I'll say it again you want to be able to
have a really professional video and
high def when you have a good
professional video in high def with good
audio horizontal shots you know nice
green background image nice well lit
it's going to come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are going
to take you seriously they're going to
see you as a professional and then share
or subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're gonna have to do it all
over again so follow these tips get a
high quality video and you should be on
your way to ranking in fact according to
backlinko you two preferably ranks HD
videos so you gotta have that 1080 pixel
size that way you know your video is
going to come across crisp and clear and
YouTube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber Watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in YouTube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
Watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your Channel The Watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your YouTube account it's it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
Studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in YouTube so here Creator
Studio on the left side navigation I'm
just going to click Channel then I'm
going to click branding and then once
you click brand name you have the
ability to add your watermark and then
you can add it to the entire video at
the end of the video at a specific start
time and then just click update and
that's pretty much it so you want to be
able to add this so that you can brand
your videos with an image and then add
that CTA so this is a good good feature
for YouTube it allows you to be
consistent with all your videos by
branding and adding that call to action
tip 7 engage with your audience so you
want to be able to interact with your
audience as much as possible just
because the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can't engage
with them so when you interact with your
viewers especially when you interact
with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want gonna
look at this okay so when you engage
you're creating a service for your
customers so here are some tips on how
to engage with your audience so first is
at the end of every video convey a thank
you message to your viewers you know
thank you for spending the time not
every busy day to watch this video you
know some of our videos go an hour plus
long and so when somebody's taking an
hour to watch a video it's only the
least you can do is thank them now you
can thank them and give them some
information about where to go for more
information because if they watch the
whole video they're already engaged and
they're probably going to want to learn
more so you always want to follow up to
thank you with where to go for more
information just like our videos always
convey at the end okay you always want
to ask your audience for their feedback
or ideas on the video so with YouTube
there's a comment section and you always
want to encourage comments so comments
can be in the form of feedback so as
you're watching this video feel free to
leave feedback on on other ways to
engage with your audience or some other
tips to increase your subscribers on
YouTube so we're always looking for
those ideas we want to keep it engaging
so somebody may have some other ideas
that we didn't think about and so we
always appreciate that from our audience
so we very much appreciate the feedback
that our audience gives us so not all
the feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively in the form of you know a
thank you for the feedback and looking
at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice because likely that
you user is going to watch the video
again so you always want to learn from
your mistakes and you want to turn those
mistakes or turn those comments into
future videos okay so create videos
based on your commenter's request the
audience has given us feedback we should
take that as positive and sometimes
that's creative sometimes those ideas
for more videos okay you always want to
ask questions to your audience and
reward excellent commenters so we try to
ask questions in our videos and when
users respond with their answer if
there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give Emoji Hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience is taking the time to give
feedback you always always want to
respond to it and you want to respond to
a positive so emojis tend to have a
positive connotation to them and so
responding with an emoji especially to a
favorite comment goes a long way so you
can reward your community both on and
off YouTube for their engagement and
support and that's just being creative
you can reward in many ways many ways
not necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
YouTube has them other platforms like
Facebook have them Instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flash so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they could see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will and to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers and subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can Captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
YouTube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and and get
their videos and use their videos and
upload them to your channel so according
to backlinko video comments of a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey do you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video I see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and I'm gonna ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free a comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
YouTube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your YouTube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how you can use different
platforms so the first thing you want to
do is look at the platforms you're
already using if you're using Facebook
and Instagram that's probably a good
place to start but there's other
platforms you can also leverage and
we're going to talk about those so
social media most companies most
individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
Facebook and Instagram so you can start
there so with Facebook you can post
something include the link of your
YouTube video with Facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your YouTube video you can
also do the same on Twitter or Instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to YouTube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the YouTube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a Blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on Reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimony and
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here touchgenics okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for AWS so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating it backlink for
us not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your YouTube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like Gmail or Yahoo or even Hotmail or
Outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your YouTube channel it doesn't
have to be to a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your YouTube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your Audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community pitch and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your video videos on
bookmarking sites like stumbledupon.com
again this is free very little time to
do this but it's a chance for you to get
the video out there and even generate a
backlink you can collaborate with other
YouTube channels this is always a good
strategy if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on YouTube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their Channel
and you could take their video and put
it on your channel in a particular
playlist okay so that's a way to
collaborate with other YouTube channels
is swap videos you could join High PR QA
sites and post answers to the questions
related to your video like core is
always a good example or ehab okay so
core there's always a question of being
posted and if you have the answer to
that question in the form of your video
then go ahead and post a response with a
link to the video on YouTube it's a
great way to get the video noticed and
it's relevant and natural okay you can
embed videos in your blog posts or if
you're using a platform like WordPress
for example very easy to go ahead and
just take that video you can even just
put the link in the blog post I like
this option I think blog posts are
always good because you don't have to be
text Heavy with a blog post you want to
create a blog post that's nice and
balanced with an image and text but if
you put a video to support your blog
post that goes even further and blog
posts themselves can be engaging and
interactive with your audience so having
a video in your blog post always goes
well in my opinion okay so you can
promote other videos in your end screen
for example at the end of your video you
can always promote something related
like we've done here in this example so
lots of ideas get your video out there
use them in email now use them in your
blog post go to free bookmarking sites
like stumble upon you know collaborate
with other people on YouTube you know go
to core respond to a question use social
media to your advantage there's lots of
opportunities to get your video out
there the more you can get your video
out there the more traffic you're gonna
get the more traffic you get to the
video the more subscribers you're going
to get so that's how the game is played
in order to get your video out there but
these are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video some
some subscribers in a world where a lot
of competing different products satisfy
the same requirements you have a lot of
advertisers who want you to try their
product and then you have other
product try my product try my product
try my product try note try my product
my product's the best no no no no no my
products the best try my product well I
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and one of the best
ways to advertise on the Internet is via
social media and through the largest
social media platform in the world and
that's Facebook so today we're going to
talk about Facebook ads tutorial and I'm
excited to teach this class my name is
Rob Sanders I'm with simply learn and
today we are going to talk about all the
different ads that Facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007 the Facebook
ads platform has grown tremendously over
the last few years almost four billion
dollars of Revenue in one year so what
does that mean that means there's a lot
of advertisers why is there a lot of
advertisers because a lot of people use
Facebook it's a pop popular platform so
not only is it popular but it's popular
with advertisers because if you're
advertising on Facebook you have the
opportunity to share your product and
your brand with users who you think are
going to buy your product or associate
with your brand and on Facebook you can
do that a number of different ways
specifically in somebody's news feed and
specifically that person's news feed
that again is interested potentially
interested in your brand your product so
there's a lot of ways to advertise and a
lot of reasons why you want to advertise
so I just mentioned one of the reasons
hey it's an opportunity for you to reach
out to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spent a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics specific
location so you're really really putting
your product out in front of the right
people at the right time and so the
other positive and pro about Facebook is
it's lesser spend greater reach and what
do we mean by that well traditionally
Facebook is a little bit cheaper than
other online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on Facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on Facebook
active on Facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
Facebook is it also has other features
other advertising features such as
retargeting so you could Target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your service or product but if they
didn't go through the conversion process
meaning they didn't go all the way
through and and buy your product you can
certainly reach out to them again just
like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform form
allows us to do that so it's a great
feature that we could take advantage of
that will talk about more throughout
this session and then it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads and and that's
primarily what most advertisers are
after you know more Revenue more sales
more leads so Facebook allows us to
educate our audience again a targeted
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back to the other
feature higher Revenue less spend this
is the primary reason because you have a
chance to influence somebody who's very
targeted who's very active on the
platform and who may have like-minded
people in their life associating with
your brand and product so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
Facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad or just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own Facebook
feed if you look so in fact I'll just
jump over to my Facebook feed right now
and if I go there what do I see I see a
single image ad here and it's from
Shopify Partners so become a Shopify
partner at eCommerce to your list of
qualifications so Shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that I'm associated with or maybe I fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my news feed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you ever
notice is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if I go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so I can't miss it if I'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see this ad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook or either that be
a friend or family members associated
with that product okay in addition to
the single image ads Facebook also has
multi-product ads or also known as
Carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you and in Carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different call
to action and so here you can see simply
learn has a exam sample of a carousel ad
where they're showcasing their different
courses so this allows users to view a
range of all your different products and
services if you have multiple products
and services to offer then the carousel
ads would be a good option for you so in
addition to the Carousel ads and single
image ads it gets a little bit more
sophisticated in terms of Technology
where Facebook allows us to offer up
video ads and so video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put a lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video video and they tend to get
about 10 to 30 percent more views than
other forms of ads so the video ads are
really a popular way for you as an
Advertiser to put your brand or product
out there so you can put your brand and
product out there and not just a few
seconds but you know really tell a nice
complete story to get the engagement to
get the person to take the action you
want them to do so that's why video ads
have become very popular because they
tend to get more engagement more
interaction than your traditional single
image ad or say your Carousel ad so
Facebook also allows us to advertise
something called lead ads and what lead
ads allow us to do is obtain user
details okay so we can acquire or get an
email address or phone number from
somebody who's interested in our product
or service and that person doesn't even
have to leave Facebook so if you look
here and they example here we have the
ad somebody clicks on sign up and they
get this form submission and the great
thing about the lead ad is that it can
sync up with any CRM or most of your
popular crms I should say for example
Salesforce as a good example of a CRM
where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
Facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or Services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
called action just like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing you know they're
different classes and then they have the
get started today call to action a
really punctuate the slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook is called The
Collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so if you're an
Advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option for you the collection
ad so here you can see the simply learn
example here they're showing you know
not only you know some some good
slideshows and imagery with some good
messaging below that so before we get
into the steps for creating an ad on
Facebook let's talk about some of the
important changes that have happened on
Facebook recently in light of data
sharing so really what Facebook's done
is they've made an important change on
how user data is being used for
advertising and so what Facebook's done
is they removed something called a
partner category and that was an ad
targeting program which the targeting
option was based on data provided by a
third-party partner so if you're an
Advertiser and you had a third party
partner that provided some targeted
options to you that was known as a
partner category and in summary Facebook
has removed that program and so now the
only way you can gain user information
is if they provide that voluntary like
the lead ad for example now you have to
get the data directly from the third
party now so you can't have that third
party give you that targeting option
anymore you can certainly again capture
the data Yourself by relying on the
capture landing pages as an example or
the lead ads and you can certainly still
Outsource your advertising to lead gen
agencies and media buying companies okay
but the partner category has more or
less gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a Facebook ad so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so when
you're setting up a campaign you have to
select what kind of spending you want to
do for your advertisement and what you
want to achieve okay so you have to in
other words identify the goal okay so
with Facebook you have two opportunities
at hand here you can jump into an
auction just like Google what you're
going to do is your ads going to enter
and into an auction and so this is where
you can decide how you want to spend
your money to achieve your goals by
choosing an appropriate bid strategy for
the auction so in the auction you're
competing with other advertisers another
option is you could do reach and
frequency and so with reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise to
your Brand's audience with a fixed cost
so reach of frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility you have
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an option and your auction is
going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency you'll be able to plan and set
up your campaigns and actually set it up
so it's more predictable on how the
delivery is going to be done with reach
and frequency so more predictability
when reaching frequency because you
could set everything up in your campaign
okay so again with the reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise
with a fixed cost auction you're not
necessarily necessarily going with the
fixed cost you're going with more
scalability flexibility on cost that can
change okay so once you choose your
objective for your advertisement then
you need to choose the type of
advertisement you want to do and it's
based on your objectives so what's your
objective is its awareness to drive
awareness is it to drive consideration
or is it to drive a conversion so these
are the three objectives uh available to
you for your advertising you want to
choose one of those objectives so let's
take a look at each of these objectives
available to you okay so let's start out
with awareness so awareness can help
with creating an interest for your
product or or your service so when we
say awareness where they can maybe brand
awareness or product awareness to get
out there in front of people okay so
with consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people to think more about our
product and service and have them take
the next step so with awareness you're
introducing your product and service
with consideration you're getting people
to take the next step and start looking
for information about the product or
service you're advertising and then
conversion is kind of that final step if
you're really after a conversion you
really want that person to make the
decision okay so they're either going to
buy or use your product or service okay
and so that's the conversion objective
so you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so when
we look at Brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase freeze awareness about our
brand or the product in our brand so
these types of objectives I mean meaning
awareness don't really emphasize
interaction okay you're not really
trying to get somebody to purchase or or
buy something or opt into a newsletter
really your goal as an Advertiser with
brand awareness is to get your product
out there so people are aware that it
exists okay let alone forget about
buying it or opting into a newsletter
you really your goal with awareness and
brand awareness is to get people to see
that you're existing your product exists
your service exists it's available and
really the aim is to create high brand
recall amongst users rather than
focusing on generating Revenue so when
we say you know High brand recall what
we mean is hey if your brand is out
there and you are really push it out
there amongst a large targeted
demographic audience then the next time
that audience sees your brand they're
going to be able to associate with it
okay it's not going to be foreign to
them or the first time they've ever seen
it you really want them to recall hey I
know that brand I've seen that brand
before okay that's kind of the reaction
you want to get from a brand awareness
hey that's a cool looking logo or man
that product looked interesting now I'm
going to take the next step so that's
what brand awareness really needs to do
it needs to create that recall for that
for your audience okay so let's take a
look now at reach so with reach reach
ensures that our advertisement is seen
by the maximum number of people within
our target audience and budget so with
reach we're really trying to reach or
get our ad out there to as many people
as possible given who we're trying to
Target and given the amount of money we
have to spend so it helps to Target a
smaller audience to visit your website
watch your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to consideration
so we talked about awareness we talked
about brand awareness and reach
with consideration we have you know
people who are willing to take that next
step okay so if we're targeting a
specific demographic and we're looking
at consideration we really want them to
do something with our ad we don't want
them just recall it or see it for the
first time we want them to take that
next step and so with consideration we
have traffic so if we have an ad you
know the least we want somebody to do
who's seen our brand before is at least
click on our ad okay so we want people
to you know click on our ad and go to
our website really that's a goal of
consideration is hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before let me click
on this and see what they have to offer
so this might involve them listening to
a podcast or reading an article or being
introduced to an app so really you're
setting the stage for further down the
funnel by further introducing them to
something that's on your website so you
really want them to take that next baby
step the next baby step is clicking on
the ad going to your site and further
educating themselves about your
particular product or service so
Facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience based
on their past Behavior okay so that's a
great thing about Facebook it's you can
really really get targeted here with
your audience okay so engagement so we
talk about traffic we're going to talk
about engagement so these types of ads
are useful when we want users to engage
more with our ad for example we can you
know really have an advertisement or
post that will allow people to like it
they can respond or even take advantage
of an offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within Facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement meant an
engagement audience for your Facebook
page that can be used for future
advertising campaigns so we're really
getting people to take that next step
and what's that next step if they don't
go to our website they can like what we
have to say and then we can have app
installs so that's another option to us
for consideration so app installs are
great if we want to send users to an app
store for example so they can download
our app so if we're really really
pushing an app that we just developed
then an app install could be a good
opportunity under consideration to allow
that user to take that next step and
download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app we have video views so
video views are are good advertisements
when you're promoting your product or
service and you really want a high
number of views so remember early on we
were talking about the types of ads
available on Facebook we talked about
video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more engagement well that's
really what we want videos to do under
consideration we really want people to
understand what we're trying to do and
really engage with our product and so
they could turn around and like it they
could turn around and push it out to
their friends so video we know is high
engaging with an audience and so having
a video allows you to really allow that
video to potentially go viral okay so
video views help users engage and
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements okay so highly engageable
you know interactive allows people to
you know really really take that next
step with your product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads ads we
mentioned in the when we're talking the
type of ads that Facebook has to offer
well Lee need ads or you know if you
have a lead generation type ad really
what you could do is you can just
collect the information so really
somebody's interest in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what I'm interested I'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes I'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your CRM
so for example Salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with Salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consider duration you know
we could drive traffic video views app
installs just regular engagement you
know and then we got Legion so we got a
lot of opportunities for consideration
if you're really trying to Target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service and then last but
certainly not least we have messaging so
with messages you know these ads aim to
convert a user's interest in a product
to a successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through Messenger so Facebook
Messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with Facebook and
so with Facebook Messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through Messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
Messenger to your advantage you can talk
right right away to somebody who is
really interested in considering your
product or service so this is kind of
the Capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of Facebook's
most popular features which is Messenger
it allows you as an Advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly turn our
attention to the last objective which is
conversion so under conversions we have
conversions product catalog sales and
store visits so for conversions really
this is the end of the funnel this is
really the part of the funnel where we
want people to take action so ads
related to the objective of conversions
really aims to increase you know
whatever the goal is of your website so
if it means sign ups or registrations
for your services or sales or downloads
or any desired action on your website
then that's the conversion okay so
that's what we're aiming to achieve when
we are tying our ads to conversions okay
so you have conversions and you have you
know pure product product catalog sales
so for product catalog sales these could
be ads to help promote your e-commerce
store or other products in your store
portfolio you know so think of Amazon
think about all the products they have
on their website you know they are
probably likely going to choose you know
product catalog sales because it really
will help really push traffic to the
store and really get somebody to convert
either in a for a particular product or
get them to look at other product
categories and buy something there so it
really really product catalog sales are
really great for future campaigns when
you're really looking for sales and then
we have store visits and so store visits
really help direct traffic to your
location and really it helps deliver ads
based on your users current location
okay so if we really want to get
somebody to the store if you have a
brick and mortar store for example then
you can use store visits as your
objective under conversions to really
Drive traffic to that location so that's
what store visits are we really want
people to you know take that next step
get to your store and check out your
store and purchase so that's what store
visits are under the conversions
objective So within each of these
advertisement objectives we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable from the
other so really you have two
advertisements that really are the same
except the only difference is there's
one thing that's altered from the other
so in this example we have a with one
promotion and then we have B which is
the same audience same everything except
a different promotion so you're really
changing one variable when you do a
split test and so that's available to
Facebook just like any other type of
advertising let's say you do you know
search advertising on Google split
testing is available let's say you do
email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
Facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad and able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25 off then hey so be it you
know it works because you tested it
against another variation and then the
great thing about testing it never ends
so if 25 off works over say two thousand
dollars off then you try something else
to see if that will increase sales
that's the whole idea behind testing is
you only want you always want to see
what works okay so really what it comes
down to is it can be really it could be
a a promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the call
to action you know a different color on
the call to action it could be anything
you want to test as long as you're able
to you know figure out what works and
then apply AI what works so you can
continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test and then
really once you identify that element
and you test it and you know what wins
then you can move on to other things to
figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
CTA so you could test things like colors
and call to actions and imaging and
messaging and positioning and you could
play around with your target audience
and test a segment of a Target on and it
gets another so there's lots of things
you could test when you a B test the
most important thing to note though when
you a B test is you always want to keep
in mind what metric you want to measure
the test up against so some of the
metrics you could use are click-through
rate which is CTR cost per click CPC you
can use conversion rate also known as CR
or just clicks the whole idea is when
you do a test and you're testing a
promotional offer you're testing even
the call to action you need to measure
that up against a metric so that metric
is what's going to determine the winner
and so it doesn't have to be overly
complicated it could be as simple as
testing you know one call to action
against another and determining which
one gets more clicks and if one gets
more clicks than the other then hey you
know you have a winner okay let's go
through the steps of creating a new
campaign on Facebook using Facebook's
ads manager so you're going to log into
facebook.com ads manager and you're just
going to click on the create new
campaign button and when you do that
you're going to see a screen that looks
just like this and you're going to go
through a series of steps so as we
presented earlier the first step is
always choosing your objective so we
have of awareness consideration and
conversion so recall that awareness was
getting your brand out there to people
who never seen your brand or product or
service before so it's a matter of
trying to reach as many people as you
can to get your brand out there and so
you have brand awareness or you have
reach remember one is controlled one is
uncontrolled okay so reach is a little
bit more control because you could set
your budget okay and you can control
your budget a little bit better so brand
awareness is just getting it out there
having Facebook plop it in front of the
ad in front of as many people as
possible with reach you are trying to
maximize how many people you show your
ad to but it is a little bit more
controlled against the budget okay
either way choosing awareness is going
to set the objective of trying to
maximize your exposure for your brand
your product or your service okay if
somebody has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services then you may
want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
Facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all of these choices are
getting somebody to do something for you
for example app installs you want them
to install your app or engagement you
want them to like or share your posts
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via Facebook's messenger uh feature
so all of these are interactions of some
sort where somebody's taking that next
step they've seen your brand they're
interested but you they're not ready
quite ready to purchase yet okay so
that's what consideration is then you
have conversion this is people in the
funnel who you know or think you know
want to convert and when I say thank you
now meaning you know you're really
targeting people who you've targeted
before who maybe has purchased from you
before or is exactly the type of
audience you're looking to purchase okay
so you have conversions you have catalog
sales and you have store traffic meaning
driving foot traffic to a store okay so
these are people further down the funnel
who you don't necessarily want to take a
smaller action like just share your
Facebook post or provide their email
address and name okay so you want them
to purchase so these are the three
marketing objectives of you're going to
choose from okay so we're just going to
choose conversions for the sake of this
example and then when we go to choose
conversions remember we can create a a b
split test okay so that's a choice you
should always choose because you always
want to be testing something okay in
this case we might want to test the app
we might want to test say the call to
action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other AD that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimization which basically allows you
to set your budget evenly across your
different ads okay and so what
Facebook's going to do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
going to be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each ad gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process is AD
set okay and as you can see here before
you even get to ad set what uh Facebook
is prompting us to do is look at
basically how the A B test is going to
work so here they're explaining how an A
B split test works okay so basically
what an A B split test does is serve up
50 50. the original versus A variation
of the original okay so that's more or
less how an A B split test works and so
Facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now notice we chose
conversions that are objective okay so
what we're going to be required to do is
put a conversion pixel on our website so
that Facebook can actually track
conversions and so what we want people
to do is purchase
and so what we need to do then is add a
Facebook pixel to our website so that
Facebook can actually track how many
people purchase from your campaign so
this is very important and so if you're
driving traffic to your website and you
want them to convert then you need to
make sure all the tracking is in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select on because the default is set
to off okay what you could do is you can
associate it with your particular
company page
on Facebook and then you're going to
create your offer so I'm going to put my
offer title I'm going to put a little
bit more details in there I can put an
end date when the offer expires in a
specific time so based on what you put
this is what people are going to see
with the ad and here you have the
Redemption section where you can have
people redeem the offer online or online
and in store so if it's online you need
to provide Facebook with a URL where
people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code or it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this Advanced option is pretty
important because if you're setting up
an offer and you only want a specific
number of people to see that offer then
and you don't want them to to share that
offer then what you could do is hide the
share option so that way people won't be
able to share the promotion with friends
or family or whatnot now they could
still copy and paste the link of the
offer but they won't be able to easily
do it with the share option and here you
could put some terms and conditions so
that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the Wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to you
know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so here we're we're choosing what we
want to split test so if we choose
creative basically what we're doing is
we're telling Facebook we want to test
our creative or ADD and so now what
we're going to do is we're going to
select the audience and so we could
choose a custom audience a look-alike or
all so here you can see we have a
look-alike and a look-alike basically is
basically what Facebook does is they're
trying to find people who are very
similar to your customers okay so that's
who you want to Target people who look
like your customers on Facebook okay so
you can choose a look-alike audience or
you could choose a custom audience if
you already have one so we're going to
create a new custom audience here
and basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell Facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where those
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to United States
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age so here
you have if you look all the way down to
13 years of age and then your range goes
all the way up to 65 years of age
then we have our gender we can choose
both men and women or just men and just
women and then we can Target a specific
language if we want to Target Spanish
people or people who speak Spanish then
we can choose Spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if I click
suggestions then for example Facebook's
going to offer us up some suggestions so
if we want to Target people who have an
interest in foreign language your
charity and causes or mindfulness or it
could be specific job titles okay so we
can get really detailed with our
targeting we also have connections so
who do we want to Target so are these
people who like our page who are friends
of people who like our page we can also
exclude people who like our pitch okay
so remember your advertising is tied to
a Facebook page however you could still
drive that traffic to your website but
what Facebook does is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a Facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community do you have on
Facebook okay so that really helps them
offer you more detailed targeting in the
form of connections okay so when we're
done we could save the audience
so I'm just going to name it uh English
and Spanish click save okay now I have
my audience saved and the important
thing here is that this audience is
saved we can use it at a later date or
if we're setting up a new campaign we
can pull from the same audience under
use a saved audience
so if I just type in English in Spanish
you'll see my audience here
okay and we can always edit it if we
need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads okay so we want to be able
to place our ads in the proper placement
and so what Facebook does is they
actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so Facebook Will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
Facebook based on the people you're
trying to Target the audience okay so in
this case we're targeting both Spanish
and English okay and we're targeting 13
to 65 year olds who live in the United
States and so what Facebook's going to
do then because we have automatic
placement set up is they're going to be
able to place our ads based on our
target audience so this is an option I
always recommend you do and Facebook
recommends as well if you're specific
about where you want your ad to be
placed then you can just select edit
placements and notice when you select
edit placements here you have different
options not only on Facebook but on
Instagram as well okay and Facebook's
Network and in Facebook Messenger so you
have all these different options
available to you if you really want your
your ad place in a specific position so
here if I just scroll over here I can
see what it looks like in a feed and
stream video I can scroll down to
Instagram that's what it looks like in a
feed on Instagram okay uh you have
Instagram stories if I want to go and
advertise on Facebook Messenger then I
have some options here in messenger
inbox or sponsored messages okay so you
have a lot of options available under
edit placements meaning picking your
placement specifically but again I
recommend as does Facebook just go with
the recommended placements for now
unless you're really clear and you
really under stand how Facebook works
and where these placements are actually
going to be but remember if you choose
edit placements and place it in a
specific position let's just say on
messenger inbox remember your audience
may not be there so go in with the
automatic placements you know is a way
for Facebook to help you get your ad in
front of the Right audience here the
next section delivery optimization okay
how much of our ads are optimized and
delivered so remember we chose
conversions here so we're going to
optimize our ads for conversions so what
Facebook's going to do is take into
account each conversion that e-chat is
getting and they're going to show that
ad that's getting more conversions more
often than the ads that aren't getting
as many conversions okay so they're
optimizing the ad delivery based on how
many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so you
can put a cost control in place so you
have an average cost per purchase okay
so Facebook will aim to get the most
purchases and spend your entire budget
okay if you put in an average cost per
purchase so for example if I'm selling
T-shirts I may not want my average cost
per purchase to be 20 dollars because
I'm not going to make any money so I'm
probably going to choose maybe two three
four even as high as five dollars on a
cost per purchase because I want to make
sure I'm not spending a lot of money
just to get a purchase so you have that
option available to you to put in as a
cost control
and here we have a conversion window and
so with this conversion window is going
to do is you know help Facebook optimize
your ads a little bit better based on
the number of conversions that happen in
this window
okay so you have some other options in
here you want to do standard delivery
add scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule or you can run them all the
time okay and then moving down to the
next option in our ad set is we have
split test and split test budget and
schedule so we have the opportunity to
put a budget in place for our ads okay
and we can schedule the the A B test to
start running immediately if we want to
or we can have the A B test run at a
specific date and we can have it run for
a specific period of time so this goes
all the way back to the first option
where we chose a b split test on step
one so we have a series of options
available to us for the split test okay
once we have all our options in place
okay we're going to click continue
and then the final step is actually
setting up our ads Okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a Facebook page it's
going to be tied to an Instagram account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
Facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have multiple images
scrolling horizontally we can have that
single image ad we can have a video we
can have a collection of images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image okay and so when we
add text in for our ad we have the
option of setting up a headline actually
it's not an option it's actually
mandatory the description is actually
optional okay but my recommendation is
you want to add a headline that's going
to grab attention and you want to add a
description to support that headline so
I always recommend putting in a
description and then once you do that
you're going to add your destination URL
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so if we have an
image here okay we can just say hey this
come check out our new product and so as
I add
this information I'll be able to view it
on the right side okay so it looks like
Facebook at this point is not able to
view the image but normally you're able
to see a preview in this case it's on
the mobile news feed so if we drop down
we can see desktop right column okay so
we need to really choose our images so
we're going to change an image here
let's see if I can choose another image
okay I'm going to choose an image here
and so now I can see the image now I
could see the headline
um and and then I could see what it
looks like just by changing the
placement okay so if I want to choose
Facebook Stories whoops that's not
available if I go to for example instant
articles okay here I can see what my ad
looks like on instant articles
so it wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of AD we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad you choose your image and you
write your headline and put your
destination URL in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're sitting once you're set
up and remember we're setting up a b
testing so that was add one now we want
to test the second ad or the variation
and so basically what we want to do is
choose the same type of format then what
we want to do is pick a variation what
is that variation going to be it could
be maybe just a different headline okay
or it could be a different URL you need
to decide what it is you're going to
test once you decide what you test
you're going to add that to variation B
once you add that the variation B then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm Facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you could see we have some
errors then we need to go back and fix
them so I'm going to go back and choose
single image ad okay so now
I could just choose my one image
so I can browse a library of images I
already have
now here's my single image ad I'm going
to add some text in there a website URL
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a B test so we're
going to set up both ads add a and add B
okay and when we do that again we can
have Facebook review it once they review
it they can confirm this you can see we
still have some errors on add a so let's
go ahead and fix that I'm going to
choose single image because that's what
add B is I'm going to browse my library
maybe I'll just test a different image
I'm going to click continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what I'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an A B test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add B and then once you do that
um here let's go ahead and fix this
error here
um the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add B
once I confirm then I have two ads ready
to go on specific placements or excuse
me automatic placements and this option
is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign on Facebook you're
choosing your objective okay then you're
setting up your ad set okay and then
once you set up your ad set with your
target audience then you're actually
going through the motions in this case
we set up two ads because we chose a b
testing okay and if you didn't choose a
b testing then you would just choose to
set up the first ad and once you do that
you confirm and voila your campaign is
set up based on these three steps okay
so let's uh review with some do's and
don'ts of Facebook so we mentioned the
types of ad that Facebook has we
mentioned how to set up a Facebook ad
itself and choosing the right objectives
and so some of the dues involved are
what just what I mentioned we always
want to do a b testing on our ads
whether that's again just changing out
the color we're changing out an image
you always want to do a b testing
because Facebook has you know Carousel
ads and because they have you know ads
that can rotate and you can use even
video with your ads you always want to
take advantage of what's given to you
and so Facebook allows you to do it do
it so if you have the opportunity to
have video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example with a presentation mode
where you could show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember it
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know and you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so remember the ads are available
to you and you have so many different
features available to you within Those
ads but that doesn't mean you got to
convolute it with messaging so keep your
message cyst consistent and simple if
it's brand awareness you know definitely
keep your message simple so that people
can understand exactly what it is your
product or service is all about then you
want to alter your reach so that the ads
are shown to the appropriate audience
okay so you always want to keep in mind
who you're trying to Target okay so you
don't want to Target somebody who's not
in your demographic so alter your reach
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience remember you have
you know reach available to you and
reach allows you to really pick and
choose exactly who you're targeting to
and how often remember you want to reach
as many people as possible but you don't
want to reach the wrong people some that
don'ts to stay some things you want to
stay away from is you don't want to put
all your money on one campaign so you
want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and I would even take that a
step further and you know put different
types of ads and different campaigns
just to see what works so again it
depends on where you're at in the funnel
if it's is brand awareness okay maybe
create a campaign for that if it's
consideration create a campaign for that
because in consideration you might have
lead ads in there I say with the
awareness campaign you may just have a
single image ad okay just to introduce
your product to somebody with a simple
message so you want to you know
definitely think about how you want to
separate out your campaigns but don't be
afraid to separate your campaigns by the
type of ads don't put too much
information in the ads remember keep it
consistent and keep it simple that's the
best thing I can say and remember a lot
of these ads are image based so images
tell a thousand words they tell a
thousand stories a video will do the job
if you have to say too much so if you're
saying too much think about a video but
if you're using an image let the image
tell the story okay don't forget to
proofread your ads I can't stress that
enough remember if you're an awareness
campaign this is the first time
somebody's seen your product service so
you definitely want to get the messaging
not only correct meaning consistent and
simple but grammatically correct you
don't want to be so active on your
Facebook page so you know when I say be
don't be so active on your Facebook page
really it depends on where you're at
you're trying to introduce a product or
service so that doesn't mean that you
need to go out and tell everybody to
start buying your product remember these
people may not even know who you are
what product and service you offer so
you want to be able to approach your
audience on your Facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
Facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts see
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising one of the biggest
challenges Facebook faces is to keep
people and businesses happy with
continuously driving change in its
functionality
recently new challenges have been added
in this light of privacy of user data
and fake news
the engine of Facebook's platform to
drive all these changes is the Facebook
algorithm
understanding Facebook without
understanding the Facebook algorithm
will limit you in efforts to use
Facebook successfully by the end of this
lesson you will be able to discuss the
recent news feed changes to explain the
concept of organic reach in Facebook
explain the new Facebook algorithm and
its main components identify the three
active interactions in the Facebook
algorithm and discuss the future of the
Facebook news feed the Facebook
algorithm is Facebook's secret Source in
which is decided which post to show in
your news feeds whether it's your
friend's post or a post from a business
Facebook has recently announced a
cleanup of the news feed which
particularly affects how businesses
should use Facebook it is now commonly
understood by businesses that to use
Facebook successfully they have to pay
to play in this lesson you will learn
about these Facebook changes in the
algorithm and what you can do to improve
your organic reach and we will close the
lesson with looking at the future of the
news feeds the Facebook news feed and
organic reach
the Facebook news feed is the core of
the Facebook platform
it was launched as far back as 2006 and
it has seen many iterations since
initially the news feed was the place to
see posts from your Facebook friends it
was the Facebook way to stay up to date
and the Facebook algorithm decides which
posts show up in what order
on top of the feed you see the what's on
your mind in which you can do your own
status updates and it allows you to add
photos videos tag people check in and so
on
Facebook continuously adds new features
that you can add to your updates
news feed is the place where you can see
the activities of your friends and the
pages that you follow you can access the
news feed on the mobile app or on your
desktop and I'm going to show here how
to access your news feed on the the
desktop by clicking here on the home
button you get access to your news feed
and in the news feed you can see all the
posts and on the top of the news feed
you have your create post section we'll
come back to that later and then
immediately be loaded you can see the
post of the various companies that you
follow or the people that that are your
friends and obviously the Facebook
algorithm and that's what we're talking
about in this module will decide which
posts it will show based on your
activities of your friends how engaging
are their posts and how many comments
are they sitting on their post and that
is a whole sort of calculation that
Facebook does to make sure it shows the
most engaging Post in your news feed
you can see how many likes they get how
many comments so you see this is a very
engaging post and here you can like
comment share the post yourself if I
click on the company name for instance
here then I would go to the company page
and then on the company page I can see
all the posts that company has done and
not necessarily all those based have
made posts have made it to your news
feed companies can use Facebook by
setting up a Facebook page and get
people to like the page and become a fan
posts done by the company would then
show up in the news feed of their fans
in the early days of the Facebook pages
this was like the Gold Rush of the 18th
century in America companies like
Coca-Cola got tens of millions of fans
and had a tremendous exposure on
Facebook and all for free but when
Facebook started to monetize their
business through advertising they needed
to find a way to push businesses in
using Facebook advertising the way they
did this was to slowly erode the organic
reach in Facebook let's look at this
organic reach in a bit more detail on
this slide you see how organic reach has
dropped over the years and how the
Facebook share price has increased they
are clearly related the share price has
gone up because a continuous drop in
organic reach forced businesses to use
Facebook advertising to reach their
audiences and this strategy clearly
works what started as small-scale
advertising opportunities for businesses
on the side of the news feed than in the
news feed and then on the mobile next
businesses could advertise in videos and
with the acquisition of Instagram and
the launch of the new Facebook Messenger
new advertising opportunities emerge for
businesses
but this drive towards growing
advertising revenues came at a price
where the news feed once was the place
where friends posted updates on what
they were doing it became a garbage bin
of business posts ads travel videos fake
news quotes and other irrelevant stuff
practically impossible for the algorithm
to manage you may have noticed this
yourself when you checked your news feed
over the years it used to be a place
where your friends shared what they were
doing
and it became a place where you could
find stuff that the Facebook algorithm
believed you liked Facebook knew it had
to do something about this the growth in
new users or slowing down there was an
increase in fake accounts fake ads and
fake news and on top of that there were
many issues on data privacy that got
reinforced because of the introduction
of the gdpr
so it was time for a change
the Facebook algorithm today
January 13 2018 goes into the Facebook
history as a significant day
so much so that Facebook lost nearly 119
billion dollars market value in one day
it was the day that Facebook announced
to clean up the news feed
Zuckerberg said in a statement that they
got feedback from their Community that's
public content like posts from
businesses Brands and media are crowding
out the personal moments that lead
people to connect with each other
Zuckerberg continues that it's easy to
understand how we got there video and
other public content have exploded on
Facebook in the last few years
but what he doesn't say is that Facebook
is a big culprit itself in polluting the
news feed by pushing more and more
businesses into advertising and by
offering more and more places on
Facebook Instagram and Messenger to
advertise
and all this pollution of the Facebook
news feed is driving Facebook away from
the most important thing it does
helping people to connect with each
other to cut a long story short Facebook
has dropped organic reach to less than
three percent
and businesses Now understand that they
have to pay to play or in other words
use Facebook advertising to reach Their
audience so where in the early years of
the Facebook page you could build your
audience and your brand organically on
Facebook and then use Facebook ads to
give your reach a boost nowadays you
have to pay to play but don't let it
scare you it doesn't have to be
expensive and Facebook has created an
amazing advertising platform that can
help you achieve your business goals and
don't worry there are still ways that
you can beat the Facebook algorithm and
improve your organic reach in the next
few slides and lessons we will explain
you how to do this
so let's look at today's Facebook
algorithm in a bit more detail the
Facebook algorithm has to make sure that
it selects the most relevant posts for
you from the thousands of potential
posts that may be displayed in